[Musique]
j'aspire le moment où le droit de grève
briatore de mogadiscio suite
[Musique]
jamais depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale n'avions nu connu une tension
aussi grande en europe dans le monde le
monde l'europe l'amérique sont sur les
dents vous le savez maintenant il est
8h30 et 1 heure du canada vladimir
poutine a lancé une offensive militaire
contre l'ukraine attaquer un pays
souverain attaquer la démocratie on a
des images de kiev depuis fort longtemps
nous n'avions pas vu des populations
civiles en europe se mettent dans des
abris on va parler dans quelques minutes
à marie-eve bédard qui était à kiev les
ukrainiens ne savent pas jusqu'où ira
vladimir poutine mais ils savent que
leur pays est attaqué l'europe est
attaqué je veux entendre deux petites
réactions il ya quelques minutes du
président français et du premier
ministre britannique pour vous montrer
la gravité du moment
en reniant sa parole en refusant la voie
diplomatique en choisissant la guerre le
président poutine n'a pas seulement
attaquée l'ukraine il a décidé de
bafouer la souveraineté de l'ukraine il
a décidé de porter la teinte la plus
grave à la paix à la stabilité dans
notre europe depuis des décennies
nous avions anticipé ensemble cette
crise en menant un dialogue exigeant et
aux côtés de nos alliés et partenaires
européens nous avons tout fait pour
l'éviter
elle est là
et nous sommes prêts à cet acte de
guerre nous répondrons sans faiblesse
avec sang-froid
détermination et unité
d'ukraine il comprit le racket résine
droid freedom démocratie
oui
oui 40,1 me not just you go away
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
s'étaient réunis hier soir tard en
suppliant vladimir poutine vous l'avez
entendu en introduction de d'arrêter ses
troupes de donner une chance à la paix
ça n'a pas fonctionné le g7 se réunit
aujourd'hui l'otan se réunit aujourd'hui
jean-philippe use on va au cours de la
matinée parler des réactions qui vont
s'accumuler en europe en amérique mais
d'abord café exactement vladimir poutine
il avait dit hier soir je vais
déstabiliser les militaires ukrainien
alors qu'at-il fait à cette heure ci en
fait juste après son allocution vladimir
poutine a lancé l'invasion il ya eu des
premières rondes d'attac qui ont lieu
durant la nuit dernière vous le voyez
ici des missiles qui ont atteint des
cibles stratégiques comme ici à yves
esnault ivano frankivsk en ukraine bien
entendu mais ce qu'on se ressemble
depuis le début de la matinée c'est qu'à
une deuxième vague de bombardements qui
est en cours présente banc afin
d'atteindre dit on du côté de la russie
des cibles stratégiques militaires au
moins deux quarantaine de soldats
ukrainiens ont péri depuis le début des
combats
donc hier soir c'est un bilan provisoire
qui a été fournie il ya déjà quelques
heures par les autorités ukrainiennes et
qui est probablement en retard sur la
réalité sur le terrain je vous le dis en
toute transparence
ce que vous voyez en arrière-plan ici ce
sont les batteries anti-aériennes de
l'ukraine qui tente de limiter l'arrivée
des missiles sur la capitale kiev avec
un succès mitigé l'ukraine dit avoir
abattu une cinquantaine de soldats
russes jusqu'à présent six avions
militaires ainsi qu'un hélicoptère un
bilan que la russie des mains mais
quelle l'ukraine soutien alors je vous
fais rapidement la géographie les points
rouges se sont tous les endroits où il
ya eu des attaques des bombardements
alors ça ne l'est plus qu'une histoire
du dôme bas sans ces deux enclaves
autoproclamés qui ont été reconnues par
la russie bombardements importants à
kiev d'ailleurs dans les dernières
heures on nous a dit que les combats
s'étaient intensifiées à l'aéroport
militaire de hausse thomel six morts à
braud verts également dans les combats à
odessa on parle de 18 morts dans les
bombardements
la russie elle accuse l'ukraine d'avoir
bombardé deux navires civils dans la mer
d'azov des informations qui n'ont pas pu
être confirmées ou encore vérifié alors
je voudrais juste pour la géographie la
distance kiev veine numéro 1 3 million
d'habitants car crif deuxième ville en
importance c'est environ 450 km entre
les deux six heures et demie de route
alors les troupes sont arrivées via le
sud le nord via le bélarus et vial est
alors ça vous donne une idée la rapidité
à laquelle la russie peut prendre
contrôle du territoire en ukraine la
russie dit viser les cibles militaires
comme par exemple ici on voit ça c'est
le quartier général de du renseignement
ukrainien à kiev qui a été atteint par
les bombardements et de ce côté c'est un
aéroport marine militaire à marioupol
marioupol qui étaient une vingtaine
kilomètres de la ligne de front du dob
basse mais ya pas que des cibles
militaires qui ont été touchés on voit
des logements ici qui ont été atteints
cet homme a été blessé donc il ya au
moins une dizaine de civils qui seraient
déjà morts depuis les bombardements d'
hier soir selon kiev et puis vous voyez
les gens se sont réveillés avec des obus
dans les rues alors la peur sur le
terrain elle est palpable et aussi les
gens font les files d'attentes pour
aller retirer de l'argent mais
maintenant il ya une limite la devise
qu'on peut retirer au guichet
automatique plusieurs ont été surpris
par cette attaque mais elle si elle
semblait si imminente depuis plusieurs
journées déjà à kharkiv ces deux files
d'attentes c'est pas pour des billets
mais c'est des gens qui font la file
pour donner du sens et au moins deux
fois plus de gens qui font la file pour
ça parce qu'il sentait que les gens vont
en avoir besoin et puis des gens aussi
se sont rassemblées sur la place
centrale afin de prier parce qu'ils se
sont réveillés donc d'une dure journée
d'un dur matin après les bombardements
et c'est totalement un état de guerre
vous le décrivez bien les gens on va se
rendre d'ailleurs sur place à kiev voir
notre camarade marie-eve bédard maria
bonjour
bonjour alors on vient de faire une
description de c2c
that at nombreuses attaques d re sur des
installations militaires sur des lieux
stratégiques comment ça se vit d'abord
où vous êtes le coma comment vous pouvez
me décrire la stupeur des ukrainiens
même si on en parle depuis plusieurs
semaines
d'abord une part d'incrédulité patrice
cette nuit on écoutait en fait aux
petites heures du matin un discours du
président vladimir poutine juste avant
le lancement de cette invasion et les
gens qui écoutaient les propos du
président menacé les ukrainiens leur
dire qu'ils allaient envahir leur pays
pour les démilitarisé mais aussi pour
enlever tous les éléments en asie au
sein de leur gouvernement avait du mal à
croire ce qu'ils entendaient même si
depuis plusieurs semaines des mois voir
on se prépare à une attaque pareil on
avait espéré jusqu'au dernier instant
qu'on allait pouvoir éviter une
confrontation d'une telle ampleur donc
il ya eu ce choc là on n'arrivait pas à
croire les propos que tenait le
président russe vladimir poutine ensuite
on assiste à une recrudescence de
l'activité les rues de kiev à ce moment
là où avant qu'on commence à entendre
les premières explosions ici dans la
capitale était assez désertes évidemment
on était en pleine nuit mais on a vu
ensuite des gens spécifique est assez
rapidement dans leurs voitures sont une
certaine agitation depuis ce matin les
principaux axes routiers tout autour de
la ville sont complètement congestionnée
parce que les gens cherchent à quitter
la capitale se mettre à l'abri loin de
ses cibles potentielles de l'armée russe
donc loin de tout ce qui en termes
d'infrastructures importantes de
ministères
d'installations militaires aussi dans
les environs la ville a été bouclé par
une série de points de contrôle c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le maire de la ville de kef
ce matin donc ce qui ralentit encore
plus la circulation
mais paradoxalement à ça il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens qu'on voit déambuler et
aller vaquer à leurs occupations
de façon assez calme de façon assez
normal les gens fait beaucoup de courses
on a vu les guichets automatiques être
pris d'assaut il ya des longues que les
gens essaient de sortir de l'argent au
cas où ce ne soit plus possible même si
le gouvernement a donné ordonné à toutes
les banques de fonctionner normalement
les courses aussi on est allé faire des
emplettes dans les quelques commerces
qui reste ouvert inquiet mais dans les
transports en commun les gens prenez le
métro et l'autobus beaucoup d'entre eux
pour aller travailler mais avec cette
angoisse on sent un niveau d'incertitude
et d'angoissé profonde sans vouloir
céder à la panique c'est un message
envoyé aux ukrainiens à de nombreuses
reprises le président volodymyr à nice
qui encore dans ses dernières
communications à la population
ukrainienne il leur a parlé à plusieurs
reprises depuis le début de l' attaque
russe sur les réseaux sociaux des
messages vidéo leur demandant de rester
calmes mais tout en leur annonçant
évidemment que leur pays était attaqué
et qu'on imposait les mesures de guerre
marie-eve ya des gens vous venez de le
dire qui fuient vers l'ouest on imagine
vers la pologne vers la rive vers la
partie plus européenne plus occidentale
de l'ukraine
là on aurait accès à des frontières
évidemment pour pouvoir quitter le pays
parce qu'il faut dire ça peut paraître
une évidence mais l'espace aérien tout
au dessus du cren il est maintenant
fermé les trains vont continuer de
fonctionner normalement sauf quelques
détours que vont emprunter certaines
lignes par exemple on parlait de l'attak
qui est en cours dans la ville de
kharkiv il n'y a pas de trains qui vont
pouvoir partir de karkhiv non plus s'y
rendre mais le gouvernement tente de
maintenir toutes les liaisons
ferroviaires pour permettre une
évacuation important de la population
parle des gens ici à kiev mais faut dire
que le gros des combats ce moment se
situe surtout dans l'est du pays et au
sud là où sont entrés les forces russes
par la crimée principalement donc il ya
une opération d'évacuation des
populations civiles qui habitent dans
ces régions-là qui s'est enclenchée
beaucoup de ces évacuations n'avons se
faire par trait on organisait aussi des
convois par autobus on continue de
tenter d'alerter la population est de
les sortir de cette zone là mais pour
l'instant on ne parle que de quelques
milliers de personnes qui ont pu monter
à bord de ces transports d'évacuation et
le gouvernement ukrainien qui dénonce le
refus de la russie d'entendre les appels
qui ont été lancés de permettre des
corridors d'évacuation sécuritaire pour
la population civile et mariam dites-moi
ce que les gens se pose comme question
ces deux vins le monstre en terme de
puissance militaire qu'est-ce que
l'ukraine est ce que le président et
veut vraiment tenté de répliquer si
tenté que l'aca étaient l'artillerie qui
est entré en jeu d'abord on a bombardé
des ddd point bien précis
si jamais il y avait une invasion plus
classique là avec avec les militaires
russes est-ce que ce qu'on dit est ce
qu'on prépare la population ukrainienne
à une réplique qui sera la plus forte
possible
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le début des
recettes invasion terrestre elle a aussi
commencé il ya des zones de combat c'est
assez difficile d'avoir une clarté
précises sur les différentes prises mais
on a vu des villes par exemple dans
l'est où les rues sont montés sur des
édifices gouvernementaux pour hisser le
drapeau russe il ya des combats le
gouvernement le ministère de la défense
le président céline ce qu'ils ont dit a
infligé des pertes importantes aux
soldats russes c'est l'ordre qu'à donner
vos l'admirer nine ski aux soldats
ukrainienne infliger le maximum
de dégâts et de pertes aux soldats
russes qui sont maintenant sur le
territoire ukrainien donc on a
l'intention de donner la réplique aux
russes dans la mesure du possible
mais ce que l'armée ukrainienne pourra
faire le poids face à cette invasion ça
c'est la grande question on a beaucoup
répété que l'armée ci n'était plus celle
de 2014 qu'elle s'était mieux entraînées
qu'elle avait été mieux équiper les
différentes armées occidentales le
canada les états-unis la france ont
contribué à professionnaliser l'armée à
lui fournir plus d'équipement du soutien
financier aussi parce que ça va suffire
pour l'instant ici l'impression c'est
que non les appels répétés se font aussi
à l'otan aux pays alliés aux pays
occidentaux pour non seulement soutenir
l'ukraine par de nouvelles sanctions
mais ça ne suffira pas l'ukraine seule
ne peut pas faire face à cette menace
qui en fait est une menace pour
l'ensemble du continent européen dans un
premier temps seul le président azzedine
ski le martèle beaucoup il faut qu'une
intervention militaire de l'otan si ce
que demandent aujourd'hui d'ukraine
demande une résolution des nations unies
aussi en outrepassant le conseil de
sécurité pour éviter que la russie ne
puisse imposer son droit de veto et
empêcher tout vol à l'action car il ya
des rencontres de l'otan qui vont se
tenir aujourd'hui demain on verra si
l'appel va être entendue mais c'est ce
qu'on souhaite ici quant au sein du
gouvernement qui est de la population je
vous dirais c'est très important puits
souligne on le sait que oui on a demandé
des armes de demander de l'argent des
armes sont arrivés de l'argent est
arrivé mais là ce qu'il demande le
président maintenant depuis plusieurs
heures c'est des militaires dans son
pays même s'il n'est pas membre de
l'otan s'ils étaient membres de l'otan
se serait automatique qui aurait une
riposte militaire c'est un pays de
l'otan ce n'est pas le cas alors on
verra il ya une réunion je le disais
plus tôt de l'otan d'urgence aujourd'hui
du g7 le président bail de n'doye par
les maquereaux a dit l'ukraine n'est pas
seul qu'est ce que ça veut dire on verra
mais avant de vous laisser aller et je
vous reparlerai tout à l'heure une
dernière question marie-eve quand
vladimir poutine près tant pis depuis un
certain temps que ce n'est pas un vrai
pays que dans le fond c'est une partie
de la russie c'est la vieille russie
est-ce que ça soude le sentiment
national ukrainien est ce que j'en parle
à nogent depuis vous êtes là vous vous
apercevez que le sentiment et craignent
et n'en sort que ressorti que renforcer
pour une grande partie de la population
c'est un coup de poignard au coeur
d'entendre des propos pareils et oui ça
vient renforcer ce sentiment
nationaliste de fierté nationale des
ukrainiens qui existent avoir une
histoire riche une langue riche aussi
pas que les eu les gens qui parlent
l'ukrainien mais chez certains
russophone aussi ça l'effet inverse
repoussant c'est à dire qu'il ya des
gens qui depuis quelques jours refuse de
parler russe bien que ce soit leur
langue maternelle et par solidarité
envers leur pays ont choisi de ne parler
que craignant pour vraiment se divorcer
de ça j'ai rencontré une dame on était
dans l'est du pays en carrière qui nous
racontait une réalité qui touche
beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui vivent sur
tout le long de la frontière avec la
russie une maman russe un papa et
craignant d'y demander moi aujourd'hui
quelle part de moi ressurgit je suis
ukrainienne 100% il faut essentiellement
tuer le russe en moi on se laisse là
dessus c'est très clair pas ça du tout
merci beaucoup marie-eve on se reparle
merci d'être là pour nous et soyez
prudentes évidemment ferry de kerchove
que vous connaissez ambassadeurs
canadiens retraités professeurs l'école
supérieure d'affaires publiques
l'inversé de sherbooke monsieur de
kharkov bonjour
l'université d'ottawa pardonnez moi
alors c'est je le disais d'entrée de jeu
jamais depuis la deuxième guerre on a eu
une menace ou si réel sur la sécurité
européenne la sécurité du monde comment
vous voyez parce que là maintenant il va
au bout de sa logique ce putin d'abord
jusqu'où ira-t-il d'après vous et les
conséquences de tout ça
je commence par ne pas froid qu'il dit
qu'il veut simplement contrôler ce qui
se passe dans le dos une base dans les
deux dans les deux provinces ce qu'il
s'est octroyé via ces petits hommes
verts depuis déjà plus de dix ans
pourquoi mener une campagne de cette
envergure avec tous les risques que cela
comporte si ce n'est pas pour remettre
l'ukraine dans le giron soviétique ou
post soviétique donc ça il ya eu
maldonne une incompréhension et c'est
évidemment délibérée de la part de food
il me dira vous savez j'ai juste changer
les choses mais je m'en irai on sait
très bien que dans les autres endroits
comme ce soit en géorgie et que ce soir
en moldavie le grignotage russe et dans
la durée et non pas dans l'instantané
donc ça c'est le premier point le second
point c'est que nous vivons un moment
historique très malheureux dans la
mesure où ça remet en cause pas
seulement l'équilibré international
parce que ça aussi fort parler mais ça
remet en cause le droit et le respect du
droit international toutes les eaux font
les institutions qui ont été créés au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
elles sont en train d'être battues en
brèche je ne dis pas que c'est pas la
première c'est pas la première fois que
ça se passe il ya eu des tas de confit
partout dans le monde y en encore que ce
soit au mali que ce soit en faillite et
d'une quantité de conflit mais ceci
c'est vraiment le bouleversement au
coeur de l'europe dudu du droit
international du respect des relations
bilatérales de l'ensemble si vous voulez
de ce que l'on appelle la civilisation
contemporaine je ne dis pas qu'elle
n'ait pas battu en brèche depuis pas mal
de temps surtout depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de pendant les quatre ans un
vendeur mais il ya quelque chose de
fondamental dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans la danse et grandes
plaines
poutine vient de changer la donne de
façon fondamentale et quels instruments
les démocraties le temps le g7 l'europe
l'amérique ou en mai pour tenter
d'arrêter poutine dans ce qu'il est en
train de faire je commencerai par dire
qu'il ne sera jamais question à court et
à moyen terme de faire rentrer l'ukraine
dans le temps même si le président
céline ce qui le supplie parce que là
nous sommes dans un conflit mondial
pratiquement inutile à l'heure actuelle
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que l'on peut
faire c'est redoublé maxime allemands
toutes les les sanctions qui ont été
annoncés mais là il faut les faire tous
azimuts et et vous avez que poutine est
déjà prêt à ça parce qu'il a menacé ce
qui veut aller bien poser encore
d'autres sanctions de représailles bon
mais il ne peut pas prendre le risque
routine de représailles qu'ils soient
militaires mails seront y aura de la
désinformation il y aura de la
cybernétique nous venons nous allons
vivre une période extrêmement peiné
parce que plus nous serrons la vis plus
nous essayons de couper
l'approvisionnement en
en hydrocarbures plus évidemment nous
allons nous faire mal à nous mêmes parce
que voilà il n'ya jamais il n'a jamais
de menaces qui soit crédible
à moins qu'elle fasse du mal à celui
qu'il a fait c'est à dire que si vous
avez une menace qui vous coûtent rien
finalement vous allez pouvoir la faire
de façon impunie tandis que c'est
certain que le monde occidental va
souffrir profondément l'inflation les
problèmes d'approvisionnement on sort de
là que vide avec avec des problèmes
d'approvisionnement il ça va ça va être
encore plus grand la fermeture ou le la
fin du contrat de nom suite y amener ne
devait amener les hydrocarbures
directement de la russie vers
l'allemagne bon celui-là est interrompue
ça ne change pas véritablement la donne
puisqu'il n'a pas été mis en marche mais
ça a quand même un impact majeur sur les
flux
les flics hydrocarbures les flux
d'énergie et dans quelle mesure est ce
que le monde va réussir à alimenter
l'europe parce que je ne sais même pas
si la russie va interrompre sa livraison
de d'hydrocarbures via l'ukraine on vit
il n'a encore une situation irréelle on
tombe à l'eau mais en même temps on
continue d'alimenter toutes ces
questions là il va falloir trouver des
réponses et la solidarité qui a
d'ailleurs été assez bien établi je
crois par bail d'un an avec ses copains
europe alors qu'au début on était
sceptiques je crois qu'il ya une seule
la vérité à long terme sur le plan
macroéconomique sur le plan financier
et ça ce n'est pas toujours très facile
je suis certain que l'on va serrer la
vis qu'on va certainement coupé l'accès
à swift vous savez le mécanisme de
transport financé dû à la russie mais là
encore dans la durée c'est à ce moment
là que l'unité s'effriter voici ce que
j'allais vous demander monsieur de
kerchove parce que à court terme bien
sûr on va entendre beaucoup de menace
aujourd'hui de la part de washington des
gens l'entendue en europe mais dans le
long terme est ce que l'europe peut se
passer totalement du gaz russe des
hydrocarbures heureuse du commerce est
ce qu'on peut exclure la russie du du
jeu international alors que la chaîne
est là dans le long terme lui se dit je
vais je vais avaler une ukraine puis
dans six mois ils vont recommencer à
acheter mon gaz
oui j'ai vécu la même période quand
j'étais à l'otan au comité économique ou
à l'époque les américains étaient très
inquiet de la dépendance européenne de
des hydrocarbures de l'urss et il y eut
finalement l'établissement d'une limite
de dépendance qui se situe aux alentours
de 30 35% dans le contexte actuel je
crois qu'il n'a encore rien ya péril
péril en la demeure je ne suis pas
certain comment on va on va s'en sortir
et c'est pour ça que je suis très
inquiet de la solidarité à long terme
bon c'est de kerchove je reviens et je
vous laisse aller après sur l'objectif à
court terme vous vous ne croyez pas
qu'il veut simplement déstabiliser
l'appareil militaire ukrainien
il est tellement rendu loin qu'il va
aller un pas de plus il va essayer de
réintégrer l'ukraine dans son giron
je suis absolument convaincu que s'il
avait pu faire la même chose en moldavie
en géorgie il ré ap ces deux petits
brimborions mais qu'il valait pas
nécessairement la peine de ceux de se
soulever l'hostilité internationale dans
le contexte de l'ukraine savez à partir
du moment où vous dit qu'un pays n'a pas
le droit d'exister que vous l'envahît
c'est pourquoi faire marche arrière je
crois que la stratégie a été très bien
développés c'est précis c'est rapide
c'est intégrer les différents éléments
militaires sont tout à fait parfaitement
en jeu et je ne vois pas pourquoi s'ils
se retiraient on va voir comment ça va
se dérouler que je ne pense pas que la
résistance ukrainienne puis c'est à ce
point formidable que poutine maille en
marche arrière est au contraire plus il
va y avoir une réaction militaire parce
qu'ils nous tirent la demande est laissé
tomber les armes est roi c'est moi
plaisir à de réaction militaire plus il
y aura de la part de poutine la volonté
de mettre fin à allah pour régime actuel
et craignait de retourner au passé parce
que n'oubliez pas il a encore sous la
dent la feuillée ne peut vite et le
maïdan sommes maidan c'est à dire le
passage de l'ukraine vers l'occident
alors que pour poutine le salut de
lucrèce est à moscou et ça je ne peux
pas croire qu'on déploie autant de force
pour simplement prendre un petit
brimborions de pays on y va fall full
games lama chaîne lama chaîne et la
machine est lancée merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur de l'expulsion merci
on ne refera pas on se reparle tamara
alter est-ce que je crois qu'on peut lui
parler vous êtes du côté russe tamara
oui bonjour tamara mais je content de
vous voir alors on sent fort depuis
trois semaines ça y est
ça y est chaque super du côté de
l'ukraine et vous êtes du côté russe
comment vous comment on vit ça
ce qui est surréaliste c'est qu'on est
dans une région qui sert de base d'une
des bases de points stratégiques pour
pour le lancement de cette de cet
affrontement militaire vous savez depuis
qu'on se parle toute la semaine on vous
a montré des temps quand vous a montré
des chars qui étaient garés qu'on
commençait à avoir circulé hier on les a
vus se diriger vers l'ukraine donc c'est
à partir d'ici qu'ils sont partis il ya
beaucoup d'activités d'ailleurs les
gouverneurs des régions ici on l'annulé
l'école pour tous les enfants on est
vraiment dans une zone d'activités
militaires c'est à partir d'ici que
l'assaut a été lancé
à 250 350 km à belgorod ça semble être
un point assez important il ya eu cette
nuit et ce matin parce que j'ai parlé
avec des gens que je connais la barre
des tirs de missiles à longue portée
donc c'est on a fermé l'espace aérien
sur une bonne partie du territoire russe
et ce jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et tout ça ce qui était intéressant puis
je dois vous lire le courriel qu'on
vient de recevoir des autorités russes
qui s'appelle censure militaire pour
vous donner une idée de ce qui rapporté
aux russes est ce qui va affecter la
façon dont ils réagissent ou pas salehi
à l'agencé roskosmos dogues qui est
l'agent dé communication issic nous
disent censure militaire que les médias
sont tenus d'utiliser exclusivement des
informations provenant des sources
officielles russes parce qu'il couvre
l'opération spéciale c'est comme ça que
c'est décrit ici dans l'est de l'ukraine
vous savez on limite l'intervention pour
le public russe et ça c'est sous peine
d'amendés et de france administrative ça
vous donne une idée de l'image du nard
actifs qui est présenté aux russes sur
la télévision d'état aujourd'hui dans
les mythes zaurus ça empêche pas les
gens d'aller s'informer ailleurs mais
c'est le portrait qu'on leur présente
monsieur poutine hier a décrit a
présenté au russe dans une allocution
pour surprise à 4 heures du matin au
moment où là ils ont commencé une
allocution il a dit c'est une opération
militaire nécessaire légitime en vertu
l'onu pour notre droit à l'autodéfense
pour carrément
démilitarisé l'ukraine comme ça qu'il a
présenté lui présente ses ça comme
l'état lui craint des temps la menace et
lui doit à les apaiser la menace contre
la russie de l'autre côté et sol et les
russes se disent que ça peut durer un
certain temps de l'opération d'air il le
dit monsieur poutine durera aussi
longtemps que nécessaire
exactement son porte parole dmitri
peskov qui parle tous les jours à 10
coeurs on n'est pas par là monsieur
élèves ce qui est seulement si le
reconnaître nous nous nos craintes par
rapport à la sécurité sécurité de
l'europe c'est le jeu du kremlin en ce
moment c'est très bien monsieur zelensky
d'hier dans son allocution au peuple
ukrainien juste avant pour les préparer
à la guerre il avait appelé au kremlin
qui l'a voulu parler à vladimir poutine
et que ça a été le silence à l'autre
bout du fil
donc les russes vous savez on n'a pas eu
le temps en toute transparence de faire
du terrain j'ai un petit échantillon de
gens à qui j'ai parlé mais le milieu de
l'as tu pas il ya une stupeur incroyable
je pense même pas que je pense je suis
convaincue pour le terrain qu'on fait
depuis des semaines déjà que personne ne
pouvait imaginer que ça irait jusque là
et ça c'est quand ils savent jusqu'où ça
va aujourd'hui
tamara vous en parliez il ya trois
semaines un mois je me souviens et vous
disiez à moscou l'appétit pour un pour
une guerre n'est pas là les gens
entendaient cela la rhétorique qui
montait de monsieur poutine je disais on
va éviter on va éviter or on est en
plein dans effectivement
on est en plein dedans et puis je sais
où est ma collègue marie ève bédard je
sais je comprends la souffrance des
ukrainiens à ce moment
des victimes collatérales en russie
aussi les sanctions dont monsieur de
kerchove parlais tout à l'heure avec
vous qui se prépare pour la russie qui
sont probablement les pires qu'elles
aient jamais connue depuis la chute de
l'union soviétique
c'est les russes qui vont en souffrir et
vous savez moi j'ai une équipe russe
c'était des gens très professionnels
qu'il dise pas un mot depuis le début de
la nuit mais qui souffre qui sauf qu'ils
sont très ce matin qui sont abasourdis
c'est grâce à eux que je suis en nombre
c'est on est dans leur pays et une
stupeur
aujourd'hui mais je pense que personne
ne saisit encore l'ampleur de ce qui est
en train d'arriver et à quel point la
russie est en train de s'isoler c'est
surtout ça on va faire du terrain on va
parler aux gens vous savez pas prise
mais je connais assez le terrain pour
vous dire que y'a personne qui est
d'accord et même même dans les entrevues
qu'on faisait hier matin dans les
villages où les temps que circulaient on
vous a parlé pète pas cette semaine les
gens le débat où ils vont entrer dans le
dôme basse
ça va être limité
on cautionnait pas nécessairement mais
on comprenait si vous voulez et quand
vous comprenez l'annexion de la crimée
mais personne ne pouvait présumer que de
l'avenir poutine allait occuper la
l'ukraine en moins 24 heures restez là
tamara j'aimerais qu'on mette la carte
s'il vous plaît d où on voit les
explosions sur la carte pour donner pour
les gens peut-être qu'ils viennent de se
joindre à nous donner
l'ampleur c'est quand même une opération
déjà qui est qui qui est très importante
bon ça c'est le début de l'histoire les
deux territoires qui avec qui on est et
monsieur poutine a décidé qu'ils étaient
désormais des territoires indépendants
pro russe mais voici voyez les les
explosions on a visé du côté russe
beaucoup d'installations militaires il
ya des morts déjà des deux côtés très
difficile d'avoir des bilans précis part
d'une quarantaine d'un côté du côté
ukrainien une 50e disent avoir abattu
des appareils russes également il ya des
soldats ya aussi l'artillerie donc d'une
part il ya des soldats russes qui sont
entrés
au nord et à l'est apparemment c'est
très difficile d'avoir un décompte
précis parce que tamara vous venez de le
dire c'est certainement pas les services
de guerre russes qui vont donner toutes
ces informations là ddd source
ukrainienne avait besoin mais vous les
voyez exactement donc c'est une
opération l'imagerie à toute la journée
et roule est
exact c'est un autre enjeu majeur
patrice il ya 80 pour ça la capacité des
forces armées russes qui étaient
déployés à partir de minuit hier aux
frontières de l'ukraine où on a fait ce
qu'on a pu filmer il ya trois semaines
on était venu à belgorod et fallait les
chercher les temps qu'on se dise on les
voit sur les images satellites on essaye
de les trouver c'était dur apprenait des
armes ils étaient cachés derrière une
forêt hier l'arsenal était
impressionnant on vous le montrer des
centaines de soldats des obusiers dans
les villages ipsen qui était devenu
presque banal savez on voyait des
enfants sortir de l'école traversée sur
les traces de neige les faits par les
tanks on a habitué un peu la population
s'installer tranquillement de préparer
l'opération et on attendait les ordres
donc l'arsenal est incroyable ce qu'on a
vu de nos propres yeux grandeur nature
laissait présager l'ampleur de
l'opération de l'opération de l'invasion
qui est menée en ce moment je sais
qu'avec vous on s'est parlé souvent à
l'émission j'ai dit moi le scénario de
larvik débarque sur kiev je ne peux pas
l'imaginer
dans nos pôles droit d'être surpris
aujourd'hui mais on ne le droit d'être
d'être sous le choc bien sûr et
intelligent ce matin possibilité que
j'avais tout à fait raison et beaucoup
de gens ce matin en se levant sont sous
le choc on a entendu les propos d'
emmanuel macron du 1er mai ce
britannique jamais depuis la deuxième
guerre
l'équilibré la sécurité les institutions
qu'on avait mis en place pour que ça ne
se reproduise plus jamais elles n'ont
autant volé en éclats
monsieur poutine décide de rentrer c'est
que comme l'ukraine ne fait pas partie
de l'otan c'est ce qui l'a choqué au
tout départ cette volonté de faire
partie de l'otan sachant que l'ukraine
ne fait pas partie de l'otan sachant que
donc il n'y allait pas avoir de réponse
automatique des membres de l'otan des
américains et des européens
il entre et avant de vous laisser je
veux souligner ce que vous avez dit ce
qui est très importante maroc vous avez
dit vous savez mon équipe et russes
c'est eux qui vont souffrir ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas les oligarques ce
n'est pas les milian milliardaire qui
vont souffrir c'est encore une fois le
peuple russe parce que les sanctions
réelles vont tomber elles seront plus
important aujourd'hui le peuple russe
qui en a connu d'autres des épreuves
peut-être un des peuples que connut le
plus d'épreuves énorme qu'ils ont une
capacité d'endurance en visite à l'essai
mais ça va être dur oui
oui je peux je pense pas qu'on puisse
dire que les oligarques souffriront pas
parce qu'on est en train de préparer des
mesures s'attaquerait à leur compte
devant des gens qui ont investi leur
argent dans les comptes de banque
étrangers on a toujours reproché
d'ailleurs au pays de l'occident qui ont
attaqué à la russie a avec des sanctions
de pau frappé assez fort
donc oui il y aura des sanctions mais
comme vous disiez probablement des
millions cachés un peu partout mais oui
c'est le peuple russe le rouble j'ai pas
pu regarder encore ce matin aux
dernières nouvelles jusqu où il était on
reparle vraiment de suspens des
transactions swift on parle de mesures
extraordinaires donc ça va être très dur
on sait aussi que la russie ait des
réserves énormes grâce à ses revenus du
pétrole
les conseils qui sont probablement
utilisé au moment où on se parle pour
financer l'invasion convoi imaginez le
coût de cette opération aussi wii vont
souffrir des russes mais aucun doute
pour moi et pour mon équipe
de vie des années difficiles que des
semaines difficiles qui servirent mais
il ya beaucoup d'incertitudes encore
pour tout le monde très bien merci
beaucoup
je hais ce qui va avoir des
manifestations je sais que sur les
réseaux sociaux les comptes télégramme
que je suis on essaye d'organiser une
manifestation dans certaines villes pour
dénoncer cette guerre on veut je pense
qu'un sentiment chez beaucoup de jeunes
surtout de montrer à à la planète ont dû
créer surtout qu'ils sont leurs frères
de sang on n'est pas pour cette galerie
mais est ce que ces manifestations
devant être permise
ça reste à voir tamara tout de suite on
se reparle merci d'être là pour nous moi
on va se rendre en direct à kiev comment
on vit avec qui on va parler une
journaliste et y en a au regard
goguenard vous êtes à broc varices et en
banlieue de kiev je crois c'est une
ville satellite et 10 km2 qui est bon
alors racontez moi votre nuit racontez
moi d'abord comment vous avez perçu et
vous vivez ce qui est en train d'arriver
je commencerai peut-être par le moment
présent parce que ça fait exactement 3 4
minutes quand on commence à entendre des
détonations venant de l'extérieur on
reçoit des messages qu'on voit à qui
hervé lie à l'état de l'état de
d'urgence les chansons invité il ya des
indices de l'amérique de descendre dans
les abris pour ceux qui peuvent donc
j'entends donc je sais pas vous n'avez
peut-être pas avec le sceau de caméras
qui est assez faible mais on entend déjà
des choses seront commencés à ce moment
là donc c'est ici cette nuit si on était
réveillé à 5 heures par des détonations
ou l'étrange de 3,4 quelqu'un que
quelques-unes ensuite bien sûr on se
jeter sur le téléphone puisqu'il y avait
des messages qui arrivent et on a bien
vu
l'animé routine en fait se prononcer et
donc on a bien vu que la vie rien qu'on
s'en fait après par contre vers six
heures de matin 6h30 de mathan ça se
calme et relativement mais à breuvart
est un peu plus tard dans la journée
vers midi vers midi on a déjà sorti les
nerveux on est parti faire des achats
ona voilà j'ai vu des gens qui étaient
sur place dans les magasins ou à côté
des distributeurs automatiques de
billets dans les stations d'essence et
donc à ce moment là il y avait encore
deux
domicile qui ont touché le var et notre
ville notamment les objets militaires
d'après ce qu'on comprend à ce moment
aussi c'est que ce sont notamment les
cibles militaires qui sont visés par des
missiles russes
parce que justement il ya des objets
militaires dans la ville où j'habite
enfin c'est donc c'était prévisible que
d'avoir ces tirs de missiles ici tout
est question est très tendue laisse
population civile essayez de d'obéir aux
ordres de gros coups un signe plutôt ou
de décence dans un client la nécessité
d' avis abri pour ceux qui peuvent nous
le métro au cip sert pour abris pour les
habitants de quillan aujourd'hui l'axé
l'entrée dans le métro dans le métro de
filière est gratuit et donc c'est bien
sûr avec une immense inquiétude de
colliers les actualités on voit que
l'armée ukrainienne se bat avec l'armée
russe dans la direction est bien sûr
très bien où traditionnellement mais
aussi il ya des mauvaises nouvelles du
côté
du côté sio2 dans goodbye l'est c'est
normal mais aussi à côté du garçon il ya
des combats tout ça a l'air extrêmement
grave on se sent comme dans un délire
irréel jamais de notre vie même il ya
malgré tout toutes les anticipations qui
ont été faites c'est à dire que nous
aurons savez les scénarios sauver toute
l'information mais jusqu'au dernier
moment malgré tout il y avait cet espoir
que poutine il n'osera pas franchir le
pas et faire l'impensable que de
bombarder que d'un petit ampli tout à
fait pacifique le pic qui veut seulement
vivre dans une démocratie qui veut son
indépendance donc en même temps on reste
optimiste ça veut dire aussi la perte de
boutines puisque politiquement olympia
mettre notre pays en 2014
récemment avec la le refus catégorique
de l'ukraine de cedeao dont les
questions de vince et l'a perdu
diplomatiquement il ya il ya presque il
ya personnes presque en ukraine qui
sympathisent à la russie
ce plus un peuple frère dont qu il ya
parle pour des sondages sociologique
bien sûr mais on est on va voir que
quelques temps que les voilà les
sympathies pour petit fantôme est donc
s'est perdu donc il nous reste que la
voie militaire et on a vraiment besoin
de soutien de nos partenaires
occidentaux
il a il a soudé l'esprit national
d'ukrainiens il a réussi à faire ça avec
séchage ces bombes oui donc avant 2014
c'était un autre qui en fait aujourd'hui
donc ça commençait à dorval ça fait huit
ans qu'on vit dans un état de guerre
mais c'est quelque chose de vivre dans
un bain vous un pays où il ya la guerre
à l'est donc c'est à dire au père se
rendra personnellement je me suis rendu
quelques fois à de basses dans les
années relais qui monte en 2015-2016 7-6
7-1 petit peu et c'est quand même autre
chose que de se réveiller dans un pays
où il ya des bombardements et tu peux tu
peux pas prévoir les situations comment
est ce que il va se dévoiler le moment
du cran pour ta sécurité pour la
sécurité de ta famille de tes enfants
c'est quelque chose d'impensable faut
dire que les ukrainiens tout aussi comme
le canadien s'est incliné sion qui
roulait génération qui vit aujourd'hui
n'ont jamais connu la guerre puisque la
génération qui a connu la guerre la
deuxième guerre mondiale et n'y ait plus
un car est mort donc ce sont quelques
générations qui connaissent pas vraiment
la vraie bière je veux dire sur tout le
territoire de l'ukraine donc pour nous
c'est quelque chose de délirant
d'impensable pas justifiée il n'y a
aucune raison pour vous quelques dates à
qui mme létard mots c'est un acte d'une
barbarie extrême on vit en 21e siècle on
qu'on voit pas quel but dans quelques
temps quel objectif que de faire et donc
c'est le moment de faire voilà de se
souder
ensemble avec les pays occidentaux
puisque il n'est pas ce n'est pas une
question de sacrifier l'ukraine ne va
pas s'arrêter là il est complètement
dans son délire historique où est
présente l'occident comme son ennemi et
le temps comme son ennemi récession est
très dangereuse et je crois qu'il faut
arrêter poutine à tout prix bon et c'est
ça le noeud de la question aujourd'hui
il y aura des sanctions énormes annoncé
il y aura washington va parler
d'ailleurs je le dis aux gens qui nous
écoutent on s'attend à ce que monsieur
byden sorte
autour de midi les les capitales
occidentales vont tout s'exprimer unes
après les autres mais fort peu probable
et personne ne voit se scénario pour
l'instant qu'il ya des militaires parce
que là votre président a demandé des
militaires après avoir demandé des armes
de l'argent à demander de l'aide
militaire à l'otan vous n'êtes pas
membre et c'est tout le dilemme de
l'otan est ce que vous craignez que
militairement il aille au bout monsieur
poutine qui l'écrasent votre pays
c'est naturel que d'avoir peur il peut
pas écraser le pied puisque sur la terre
quand même l'armée ukrainienne surtout
côté est et les très fortes elle est
très forte parce que ça fait huit ans
qu'il est en guerre et il campe là donc
il est très très forte
notre point de faiblesse c'est l'air en
fait la défense aérienne et ça c'était
aussi sur claude avance et ce qui est
peut-être ce que peut être un sujet de
discussion aujourd'hui c'est la firme et
thurau l'aide de l'otan de la fermeture
de l'ers la protection par laird et
l'ukraine puisque c'est là qu'on est le
plus vulnérable le plus fragile et c'est
comme ça qu'il va vite il va avancer
d'une manière très rapide et qu'il peut
vraiment détruire en fait puisqu'il n'ya
pas de des moyens de défense efficace
contre cela donc
parce que quand monsieur macron dit nous
sommes avec l'ukraine nous allons être
au côté de l'ukraine qu'est ce que vous
entendez quand il dit ça qu'est ce que
vous espérez
nous espérons
plusieurs choses nous espérons tout
d'abord à l'esprit de solidarité
diplomatique nous espérons bien sûr les
sanctions les plus fermes possibles
et les sanctions qui agissent vite nous
espérons bien sûr l'aide militaire en
termes de matériel en termes de dar el
caetera et nous espérons aussi laide
comme je viens de dire de protégez l'air
e -u craignant contre les missions et
les avions russes puisque ceux ci il va
très vite voyez quand il ya des avions
qui bombardent les grandes villes ça va
très vite donc c'est qu'ils me barbarie
c'est absolument inacceptable que de
bombarder des civils qui peuvent pas se
défendre donc c'est vraiment
c'est inacceptable en fait
merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé on se
reparlera peut-être tatiana golikova
merci infiniment on comprends l'angoissé
dans laquelle vous êtes plongé et je
retiens un mot de ce que vous m'avez dit
le délire vous dites nous de notre côté
on perçoit un délire paranoïaque un
délire dangereux du côté de notre voisin
russe et jusqu'où tout ça ira merci
beaucoup on va suivre sont le temps
qu'ils le font bien sûr merci au revoir
à bientôt bonne chance
gaston côté que vous connaissez
brigadier général à la retraite des
forces canadiennes
bonjour général vous allez bien
aujourd'hui un wii connaît
qu'à expliquer à nos téléspectateurs la
stratégie militaire de poutine on va
revoir cette carte là ils s'attaquent à
des installations militaires il veut
mettre à terre la capacité militaire
ukrainienne soit
oui effectivement alors dans un premier
temps je pense que ce qui était ciblé
c'était pratiquement tous les les zones
de radars
près des aéroports ainsi que les dépôts
de munitions il ya certains des
explosions qu'on pouvait voir cette nuit
qui était réellement là on avait une
table m'a frappé dans le mille pour
dépôt de munitions parce qu'il y avait
énormément de de l'explosion
subséquentes qui indique justement qu'on
a frappé un dépôt de munitions ça
c'était pratiquement pas loin de kiev en
fait où on a vu ce genre de choses qui
se passent faut dire que depuis quelques
années on a
goa envoyé beaucoup de munitions de
différents types à l'ukraine pour
qu'elle soit en mesure de se défendre
des jeunes c'est passionnant vu
l'occasion finalement donné mais dans
des entrepôts il aurait été plus
sécuritaire
et gars son côté la prochaine étape dans
votre esprit le caylar thierry la
prochaine étape est ce que c'est les
chars est ce qu'on entre encore plus
loin
comment vous voyez la suite des choses
militaire mais
ils vont certainement déployé des chars
sur le front est pour faire la liaison
avec le donne basse on a déjà des
informations à l'effet que les forces
qui ont renforcé les séparatistes dans
ces deux régions là ont réussi à faire
une percée et puis passer au delà de la
ligne de front de plus de 3 km alors on
m'a donné un voyage liaison qui va être
effectué justement afin de renforcer
cette région on sait aussi qu'il ya eu
des débats que magna quoi il écrit mais
ils sont aussi par des troupes
probablement d'infanterie marine qui
était là et qu'ils étaient sous et sur
des bateaux a reçu bien qu'ils étaient
déjà déployés en crimée et ça ça leur
permet à ce moment là de prendre le
contrôle ou six une région portuaire qui
était ce intéressant et surtout dans les
régions d'odessa de l'est ils
avanceraient vers le centre vers kiev il
pourrait descendre du nord vers kiev
également
effectivement en fait ce qu'on redoutait
ou ce qu'on nous tout ce qu'on espérait
plutôt avec
la percée à partir de la biélorussie
c'est que les marécages de prix pet à
l'ailé des retards des maisons
simplement passer par l'autoroute alors
il m'a rejoint de dino si cet obstacle
qui a toujours été historiquement
un réel mal comme un champ de mines il y
aurait été capable de 110 et s'il était
s'il avait été tout terrain mais ils ont
décidé de prendre l'autoroute alors sa
tête un peu désamorcé le dispositif de
défense ukrainien dans ce secteur là du
côté de l'est pas ce qu'on remarque
aussi c'est qu'il ya des bombardements
d'artillerie je sois parmi ces nous
vient par canon et la capacité de
thierry soviétique est réellement
supérieur à ce que l'ukraine peut
engager parce qu'on appelle des feux de
contre batterie c'est à dire et c'est
neutraliser finalement l'artillerie
soviétique alors il ya des canons tout à
fait
développer la fine pointe de la
technologie russe depuis quelques années
et ceux ci ont déporté tout à fait
incroyable un canon canadienne auto
massa serait à peu près 20 km mais pour
canon similaires sont on parle de 70 km
lancées c'est difficile à atteindre
c'est une des machines de guerre les
plus puissantes sur la planète disons la
russie et l'artillerie notamment quand
vous dites le vent de 20 ses forces
russes comment vous pouvez qualifier les
farces ukrainienne qu'est ce qu'ils ont
dans leur jeu
aux deux chrétiennes avaient beaucoup
d'équipements lorsque il ya eu la
séparation avec la russie mais cet
équipement la a été laissée en désuétude
et puis il ya eu effectivement peu de
développement juste pour contredire un
peu l'aspect fun précédente le plus gros
développement que le l'ukraine a réussi
c'est la création d'une bonne base au
niveau de la défense aérienne mais cette
base qu'ils ont c'est réellement d'avoir
des radars maintenant qu'ils peuvent
contrôler le tir de missile jusqu'à 400
km jusqu'au bout vous expliquer c'est
que le râble de radar peut détecter une
cible qui se trouvent ses volants qui se
trouve à 400 km de long est engagé
finalement un missile qui lui vaut être
à peu près à 30 km de la cible on vise
alors si c'est réellement une prouesse
technologique qui toutes
n'ont pas l'avantagé
important du côté ukrainien dites vous
c'est un aspect portait encore une fois
ces mineurs parce qu'encore une fois de
la capacité des heureuses de déployer
des avions de chasse les hélicoptères
est quand même assez considérable
combien de temps d'après vous
monsieur poutine s'est donné pour
avancer comme ça parce que le sud de
kerkhof l'a dit très clairement plus
beaucoup le disent aujourd'hui un peu
partout sur la planète il s'arrêtera pas
en chemin il en serait très étonnée que
s'arrête en chemin je me suis donc
combien de combien vous voyez le
déroulement de l'opération l'un terme de
deux jours de heurts
honda 72 heures je pense d'eux après
avoir pris le contrôle de la majorité
des points d'intérêt évidemment ce qui
donne ce qui est important pour eux ces
deux captures et finalement le
commandement contrôle du pays thomas dit
le président et les généraux qui sont
sans doute dans un un conseil de guerre
à kiev et puis à ce moment locke
deviennent incapables finalement
d'organiser une riposte
ou une défense contre les russes alors
ça ça peut se faire relativement
rapidement surtout que et leurs troupes
mécanisées avancent très rapidement
vous savez là quand on regarde
l'histoire récente de l'ukraine où il a
une expérience de combat mais cette
expérience là était réellement dans un
combat statique là de façon à endiguer
les troupes qui était dans le donbass
mais maintenant ce qu'on parle c'est une
guerre mobile et ça je pense que
peut-être pas nécessairement tous les
atouts ou l'entraînement où l'expérience
pour pouvoir réellement passé de
subtiles de guerre là donc on va d'après
vous au cours des 72 prochaines heures
assister à une attaque
violentée décision sur une démocratie et
on va voir sous nos yeux une démocratie
tombé à genoux
ce soit possible en effet c'est pas
c'est pas un sou et la passe mais c'est
injuste une analyse des capacités
militaires des deux côtés et de ce fait
là ils ont réellement la capacité pour
envahir le pays rapidement ce qui se
passera une fois qu'ils auront fait ça
et décapité si on veut le régime ont
décapité au point du commandement
contrôle pour physiquement à ce moment
là il ya une question qui se pose est ce
qu'ils vont réellement avoir une armée
d'occupation
on sait que monsieur poutine a déjà
mentionné qu'ils n'étaient pas
intéressés à occuper
l'ukraine et il est parfaitement raison
parce qu'une fois que l'armée se
transforme en armée d'occupation il
court le risque effectivement de se
retrouver dans la même situation que
l'armée russe en afghanistan où tout le
monde se mobilise finalement contre
l'occupant et puis facilement peuvent
être réduits grignoter finalement à la
longue il veut je pense que c'est pas
aller trop loin que le dire il veut
installer un régime pro russes là et
pouvoir se retirer puis à voir donc
l'ukraine dans son giron totalement sans
avoir comme vous êtes à occuper le pays
parce que le sentiment national
ukrainien on en parle à nos camarades
sur place à cette journaliste ukrainien
il est fort la pluie plus la montrer les
muscles plus il est l'agresseur plus les
ukrainiens se dit c'est pas vrai nous ne
sommes plus russe les gens refusent de
parler russe depuis quelques jours
d'abord et c'est une langue qui usuels
un grain
effectivement et puis encore une fois
vous savez j'ai vu beaucoup de
raccourcis historiques de lasbordes du
président poutine concernant
l'appartenance de l'ukraine à la russie
c'est vrai que le kiev a été finalement
le siège la création de la russie mais
depuis ce temps là disons que la russie
n'a jamais traité l'ukraine de façon
très très gentille on se rappellera que
cette allée organiser une famine en fait
qui a réellement mis à terre beaucoup de
millions d'ukrainiens en 32 morts
évidemment et qui a entraîné un exode
massif des ukrainiens à des pays comme
le canada et xavier puis il ya eu aussi
des luttes justement de façon à ce qu'on
puisse obliger les ukrainiens à prendre
leurs oeufs c'est non pas juste la
langue ukrainienne alors depuis quelques
temps cependant la tendance est
renforcée s'est inversée par dont
l'effet que l'enseignement du russe
maintenant était avait pris le second
second pas sur l'enseignement de
l'ukrainien d'un pays quel son côté vous
restez avec nous on va se reparler plus
tard on va aller à ta voix parce que je
le disais merci beaucoup quel son côté
on va aller l'arrêté avoir toutes les
capitales les unes après les autres
montrent leur
indique un monsieur poutine qu elles
vont tout faire dans la dans leurs
moyens pour sanction et compagnie pour
tenter de de le faire reculer jusqu ici
ça n'a évidemment pas fonctionné on le
voit laurence martin d'abord le canada a
fermé son ambassade en ukraine ce
dossier c'est c'est une évidence et la
question qui se pose est ce que monsieur
trudeau ne va pas publiquement parlé on
va attendre monsieur bail de ne parle
d'ici quelques heures et on attend
justement des précisions la part du
gouvernent du bureau du premier ministre
trudeau on nous a dit sans doute un
point de presse en début ou en fin
d'après midi on verra aussi du côté de
mélanie joly mais juste pour revenir sur
l'ambassade patrice parce que ça a été
confirmé à quelques minutes en fait
c'est notre collègue me rebooste ur de
cible ici qui est sur place en ukraine
selon ces sources donc le canada qui
affirme il a tout récemment son
ambassade à lviv elle n'était plus en
fait à kiev dans la capitale parce que
déjà deux semaines la ministre mélanie
joly des affaires étrangères avait
indiqué qu'il déplaçait l'ambassade vers
l'ouest du pays justement parce qu'il
craignait une invasion russe et là ce
qu'on apprend c'est que donc cette
ambassade qui était à lviv dans l'ouest
du pays maintenant le personnel à
l'ambassadrice serait se déplacerait
vers la pologne d'aucun pays limitrophes
alors évidemment il ya des questions qui
se posent pour les canadiens qui reste
en ukraine quel genre de service est ce
qu'ils vont recevoir s'ils veulent
quitter le pays on sait que la ministre
je lis déjà il ya quelques semaines
s'était entendu avec plusieurs pays
limitrophes à quatre pays la pologne la
roumanie la hongrie la slovaquie pour
permettre aux canadiens qui sont en
ukraine de pouvoir sortir la de
l'ukraine sans entrave donc on verra
évidemment on attend les détails là du
bureau de madame joly mais c'est un
développement la dernière est d'autant
que notre
collaboratrice à kiev
marie-eve mais cette ukrainienne à qui
on vient de parler dire on entende on
entend des explosions donc alors oui on
avait vous avez raison de le souligner
est déplacé à lviv près de la pole
sommes là exactement occidentale bon
monsieur trudeau va participer au g7 oui
même en ce moment va parler la question
qui se pose c'est que peuvent faire les
les démocraties sur la planète 2 face à
ce coup de force oui parce que bon déjà
mardi monsieur trudeau avait annoncé des
sanctions économiques entre autres par
exemple contre des banques russes deux
banques russes qui sont sous influence
de l'état de monsieur poutine on avait
aussi interdit aux canadiens de
participer à des achats de la dette
souveraine russe est ce qu'on va vouloir
aujourd'hui annoncé de nouvelles
sanctions économiques est ce qu'on va
vouloir aller plus loin c'est ce qu'on
verra je pense qu'on peut voir une
réaction sur twitter de monsieur trudeau
là qu'il a fait hier soir où il dit le
canada condamne vivement la techno
provoquer de la russie contre l'ukraine
une autre violation flagrante de la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine et des
obligations de la russie aux termes du
droit international de la charte des
nations unies et dans cette même
déclaration le monsieur trudeau a dit
qu'il y allait avoir de nouvelles
sanctions contre la russie de nouvelles
mesures ce qu'il faut comprendre patrice
quand même c'est que le canada reste un
petit joueur dans toute cette escalade
convoi jusqu'à maintenant ce n'est pas
un joueur d'avant pleurs bon c'est vrai
qu'au canada il ya quand même une grande
communauté d'origine ukrainienne la
troisième plus grande au monde après
celles qui se trouvent évidemment en
ukraine et en russie donc il ya beaucoup
de canadiens qui regardent avec beaucoup
d'intérêt beaucoup d'inquiétude ce qui
se passe en ce moment dans leur pays
d'origine on n'a qu'à penser à notre
vice première ministre mme adam freeland
qui est d'origine ukrainienne mais comme
je le disais le canada est un petit
joueur et on n'a peut-être pas non plus
de deux grandes cartes de pour faire
pression sur monsieur poutine quand on
pense par exemple un pays comme
l'allemagne qui est le gazoduc
nordstream deux cantons passent par
exemple à l'angleterre où il ya un
secteur financier où les russes ont
beaucoup d'influencé sur que l'acier ou
bloquent des accès si on ferme des
comptes de banque ça peut exercer une
pression forte sur la russie le canada
n'a peut-être pas cette carte à jouer
mais c'est clair qu'il va vouloir faire
front commun avec ses alliés du g7 donc
on surveillera évidemment là ce qui va
être annoncé un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut entendre
un extrait de bob rae qui est
l'ambassadeur canadien à l'onu qui n'a
pas été tendre envers monsieur poutine
et
évidemment pour un pays comme le canada
comme plein pays européens voire toute
la question des réfugiés aussi qui va
finir par se poser qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec ces gens qui vont fuir
l'ukraine et bien justement le premier
ministre québécois françois legault
vient de publier un message sur facebook
je pense qu'on peut le voir ont ils dit
on s'est réveillé avec des images
horribles une nouvelle guerre en europe
ce matin on espérait ne jamais revoir ça
le québec va faire sa part pour
accueillir des réfugiés ukrainien dans
les semaines et les mois à venir on se
tient également prêt à offrir une aide
matérielle humanitaire dans la mesure du
possible donc évidemment à suivre plus
tard aujourd'hui
tous les citoyens en tout cas des
démocraties entre qui suivent ce qui se
passe sur la scène internationale se
sont réveillés ce matin avec des scènes
d'horreur dans leur tête est-ce que
jusqu'où tout ça ira parce que depuis un
mois ou un mois et demi on dit oui mais
il ya beaucoup de rhétorique mail aux
repas or non seulement il a osé son plan
et méthodique qu'il veut mettre à terre
le régime démocratique on oublie le
souligner beaucoup là l'ukraine est un
régime démocratique et c'est aussi ça
une menace aux yeux de vladimir poutine
n'ont pas l'entrée éventuelle oui à
l'otan bien sûr qu'il n'en veut pas il
ne veut pas le temps à ses portes mais
il ne veut pas non plus d'une démocratie
a ses portes alors on va suivre ça
laurence il y aura des conférences de
presse et monsieur truc dont on suit
merci beaucoup on va se rendre à paris
celui qui a donné le ton raphaël bouvier
bonjour c'est le président de la grande
ce matin ce matin notre heure bien sûr
vous
il était midi monsieur macron qui a
donné le ton avec un discours très
sombre en dix ans nous serons aux côtés
des ukrainiens la question c'est
militairement non pas vraiment alors est
ce que vraiment les sanctions vont
suffire on voit que non alors on est un
peu dans ce
marasme là dans la réponse occidental
oui il a voulu envoyer un message fort
emmanuel macron c'est vrai patrice et
vous aurez remarqué que derrière lui
avait le drapeau de la france celui de
l'union européenne et celui de l'ukraine
également et donc monsieur macron a dit
qu'il y aura une réponse sans faiblesse
de sang froid en solidarité
mais c'est vrai qu'on se demande quelle
forme prendra cette réponse à la fois
emmanuel macron et boris johnson ont
utilisé dans leur adresse respectives à
la nation le terme militaire qu'est ce
que ça veut dire on ne s'attend pas
évidemment à une participation militaire
active sur le terrain l'ukraine n'est
pas un pays membre de l'otan vous
l'avais répété à plusieurs reprises au
cours de l'émission et le temps ce matin
a dit ben nous on est prêt à augmenter
notre présence dans la périphérie de ce
conflit là donc chez nos membres les
pays qui sont qui font partie de
l'alliance et qui se trouve près de la
frontière avec soi l'ukraine la
biélorussie ou encore la russie penser
aux pays bas la pologne mais il n'est
pas question d'aller en ukraine alors
l'autre option qui est toujours sur la
table évidemment c'est celle des
sanctions il ya déjà des sanctions
économiques qui ont été annoncées par le
royaume uni par l'union européenne plus
tôt cette semaine on a entre autres
cibles et des institutions institutions
bancaires un peu comme l'a fait le
canada mais aussi des individus il y
avait eu des élus entre autres la les
élus de la douma russe qui ont appuyé la
déclaration d'indépendance par vladimir
poutine de ces deux territoires à l'est
de l'ukraine et aussi on a ciblé des
proches de vladimir poutine entre autres
le ministre de la défense le chef de
cabinet de monsieur poutine et là on se
prépare à annoncer d'autres sanctions à
l'endroit de la russie l'union
européenne a convoqué les ambassadeurs
des vingt-sept
éparses et action là et ce sont les
dirigeants des 27 pays qui vont se
réunir dans cadre d'une rencontre d'une
réunion extraordinaire à bruxelles ce
soir pour approuver ce plan là ce que
dit l'union européenne c'est que ce
seront les sanctions les plus sévères
que l'organisation n'a jamais imposé
quelle forme ça va prendre on verra bien
et surtout qu'elle portait cela aura
auprès de la russie c'est la grande
question qui se pose en ce moment en
europe mais clairement pas très son sens
l'inquiétude des dirigeants européens
qui ont souligné que c'est non seulement
l'ukraine qui a été attaquée mais c'est
une démocratie en europe qui est la
cible d'une attaque aujourd'hui c'est un
mot qui est beaucoup revenu dans les
discours et il ya entre autres le
secrétaire général de l'otan qui disait
qu'une attaque de cette force là sur le
continent européen c'est quelque chose
qu'on pensait être réservé à l'histoire
et dénonça se produit aujourd'hui on
sent la nervosité des dirigeants
européens on va si vous le voulez bien
écoutez un extrait de ce discours
chambre
solennelle de monsieur maquereau
en refusant la voie diplomatique en
choisissant la guerre le président
poutine n'a pas seulement attaquée
l'ukraine il a décidé de bafouer la
souveraineté
de l'ukraine il a décidé de porter la
teinte la plus grave à la paix à la
stabilité dans notre europe depuis des
décennies
alors voilà
la grande question on a parlé plutôt est
ce que l'europe va pouvoir se passer du
gaz russe très longtemps parce que
l'allemagne oui on a suspendu cet
important
projet d'agrandissement en fait plonger
il est fini le gazoduc stream 2 mai mais
combien de temps est-ce que dans deux
mois trois mois subtil se dit moi je
suis prêt à prendre la pression le
peuple russe on est des jeux vidéo et
dans six mois on verra qui qui est
encore là et moi j'aurais l'ukraine de
mon côté bref c'est sûr instinct ce
serait important à surveiller patrice
effectivement parce que c'est quand même
une grande décision qui a été prise par
l'allemagne est un pays dont les
importations de gaz dépendent en grande
partie du gaz russe mais il faut
comprendre aussi qu'en ce moment dans
plusieurs pays européens on traverse une
crise énergétique
il ya des prix à la consommation qui
sont très importants on en parle en
allemagne entre autres c'est un sujet
aussi qui revient dans les discussions
autour de la campagne française le prix
de l'énergie le prix du carburant et
tout ça pourrait revenir évidemment dans
le débat alors pour l'instant on sent
qu'il ya une unité claire au sein des
membres de l'union européenne même que
des pays qui sont parfois en conflit
avec bruxelles sur toutes sortes de
sujets penser à la pologne et à la
hongrie ils sont derrière l'union
européenne pour imposer des sanctions à
la russie est ce que le bloc est ce que
l'unité va tenir on va surveiller et
cette question énergétique pourrait
s'inviter dans le débat si tout ça
s'étire dans le temps évidemment on va
écouter
un extrait justement qui résume la
position du nom refait un
rallye de chypre fait sans précédent
dans les relations
les notes à quest ou neufbox
10 notre christophe diplomatique
provoquée il se met hors life and death
in the ballad of which have agro
beaucoup mieux l'été
la russie sera frappée d'un isolement
sans précédent plaide-t-il l'otan
revenons à l'hôte à la quête dans quelle
mesure bien sûr ce n'est pas un pays
membre je le répète on peut pas répondre
directement contre les armées russes
mais on peut renforcer autour entre
autres
oui exactement ici ce qui a été annoncé
ce matin on veut donc déployer davantage
de troupes vous savez le canada avait
annoncé plus tôt cette semaine l'envoi
de troupes supplémentaires en lettonie
c'est là que le canada est présent mais
à d'autres pays membres de l'otan qui
ont des troupes qui sont déployés
ailleurs dans la région les etats-unis
sont en pologne l'allemagne et en
lituanie à des troupes d'autres pays en
estonie alors le but c'est d'envoyer
davantage de troupes dans ces régions
périphériques qui sont prêts donc je le
disais de l'ukraine mais aussi de la
russie et du bélarus sont impayés duquel
son parti des troubles des troupes
russes de surpayer pays qui a hébergé
des troupes russes alors on veut
s'assurer que les alliés soient protégés
pour ce qui est du rôle que peut jouer
le temps en lien avec l'ukraine
directement bien ce rôle là il est plus
limité compte tenu du fait que l'ukraine
ne fait pas partie de l'alliance et on
pourrait en savoir davantage sur la
stratégie de l'alliance atlantique au
cours des prochains jours évidemment il
ya toutes sortes de rencontres là de
haut niveau il ya l'union européenne qui
se rencontrent aujourd'hui il ya le g7
vous en parlais tout à l'heure il
rencontre de l'otan demain et on verra
ce qui en ressort parce qu'on sent une
nervosité justement pas très chez
certains de ses membres qui sont en
europe de l'est en europe du nord et
d'ailleurs fait intéressant ça a été
soulignée sur les réseaux sociaux demain
à cette rencontre de le temps il devrait
y avoir deux pays qui ne sont pas
membres de l'alliance la suède et la
finlande mais qui sont invités à y
participer 5e dans toutes ces régions
qui sont situées près de la rue si on
est assez nerveux face à ce qui se passe
en ukraine en ce moment on écoute le
secrétaire général
puis son art compte notre as been
château 2
we know in europe en scale and over and
over hype en
place qui appartenait l'ampleur de la
tâche qui appartenait invité lui aussi à
sa façon à l'histoire ça revient
beaucoup depuis ce matin donc stupeur on
ne pensait pas revoir sur le sol
européen ce genre d'attaqué maintenant
les chars qui font le leur avancée en
ukraine merci beaucoup on se reparle
bien sûr je valais à washington parce
qu'une des réactions que l'on suit c'est
celle de joe biden qui très tôt ce matin
à l'aube se serait entretenu avec le
président ukrainien parce qu'elle a reçu
mme jullien terme washington bonjour
patrice bon g7 on le disait alors
réunion actuellement 1 en fait je pense
que monsieur bâle ii ne participent à la
réunion actuellement et on attend
ensuite une déclaration publique là
exactement déjà très tôt etc les
informations des premières informations
qui perd col de la maison blanche joe
biden a rencontré ces spécialistes dans
la salle de crise la maison blanche pour
faire le point sur la situation et
surtout déjà discuté de quelles seraient
les répercussions pour la russie avec
cette décision d'aller de l'avant avec
cette opération militaire l'a donc il ya
eu cette rencontre leur on a répété dans
le communiqué envoyé par la maison
blanche qu'il s'agissait là d'une
opération non provoquée non injustifiée
déjà hier soir on
promettait que les états unis allaient
discuter avec ses pairs ses collègues
sur la scène internationale pour
s'entendre sur quel type de sanctions
ils pourraient être et avoir d'ajouter
parce qu'il y en a déjà qui ont été
prononcées et adoptez donc ce matin joe
biden a rencontré son équipe il est avec
le g7 en rencontres à distance bien
évidemment pour discuter avec la
communauté internationale et le moment
où il sortira parce qu'il a déjà annoncé
hier soir qu'il veut sortir pour
expliquer aux américains ce que les
états unis vont tenter de faire pour
répondre aux gestes de vladimir poutine
certains médias parlent d'une sortie à
midi mais pour l'instant la maison
blanche dit que ce soit en début en
début d'après midi bon on va bien sûr
suivra en direct déclarations de
monsieur by john qui sera suivi par ce
que
parce que là où il y avait une première
vague c'est comme ça que ça avait été
présentée de sanctions là faut que les
gens comprennent que la deuxième vague
elle doit faire mal et poste au peuple
russe à suivre hier soir le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu j'en parlais plus tôt
s'est rencontrés d'urgence pour il ya eu
un plaidoyer assez émotif du secrétaire
général des nations unies du thérèse en
disant monsieur poutine
arrêtez vos troupes donner une chance à
la paix ça évidemment pas été entendu
par yves piste chaîne c'est quand même
une phrase qui résonne
antonio guterres elle a commencé cette
réunion là justement en rappelant qu'il
avait pris la parole le matin même sur
ce même sujet sur le sujet de l'ukraine
il a dit écoutez je vais pas imposer à
mes collègues le même discours et leur
répéter celui que j'ai fait ce matin est
donc il était très succinct mettrait
elle émotive presque jeudi en appelant
justement la russie a reculé à 2 à
donner une chance au processus de paix
et ç'a vraiment été un moment très
particulier patrice parce que la
rencontre a commencé vers 21h30 à new
york au conseil de sécurité et quelques
minutes après c'est ça à ce moment là
que vladimir poutine a pris la parole
pour annoncer cette opération un
militaire spéciale en ukraine et ça a
pris un très long moment avant que les
membres du conseil de sécurité
apprennent apprennent cette nouvelle là
en fait ils ont appris parce que le
représentant de la russie à l'onu qui
était aussi le président de l'assemblée
hier soir l'annoncé à ses collègues en
disant que la russie allait lancer une
opération militaire en ukraine que
c'était en riposte en fait à la
souffrance des gens du donbass et que
c'était est légale de le faire selon
leur interprétation de la convention de
l'onu donc
il me pays membres et ceux qui étaient
présents à la table on appris de cette
façon là est la personne qui a pris la
parole juste après le représentant de la
russie eh bien c'était le représentant
de l'ukraine qui lui aussi était
non seulement surpris mais il allait pas
nécessairement sortie de ce protocole
mais il a réclamé de son vis-à-vis russe
de cesser toute opération militaire
lui-même dit écoutez on peut prendre une
pause vous pouvez prendre une pause
allait prendre le téléphone aller parler
à votre président pour que cette
opération militaire la cesse et patrice
j'aimerais ça qu'on écoute les derniers
mots de cette rencontre d'urgence là
qu'ils ont été prononcés justement par
le représentant de l'ukraine c'était ma
foi très fort
groupe i think we love love to stop
agression
comme les de ces jeunes au sam mendes
qu'aux
états unis la jeunesse
alors et vous avez raison
quand on a écouté ce hier en direct on
se disait là
l'arrêt est ce que vraiment on vit ça
notre collègue journaliste ukrainien ne
parlait de délire surnaturel on est
vraiment dans une situation une
démocratie a été attaquée et là les
supplications conseil de sécurité non
évidemment absolument rien donné merci
donc pascal on suit on suit la
déclaration ou la conférence de presse
entre la déclaration publique de
masseube hayden quelque part en début
d'après midi évidemment qu'on va donner
tout ça en direct merci on se reparle
merci beaucoup rafa est jacob
bonsoir bonjour raphaël et je parle de
ce conseil de sécurité hier quand même
particulier on parle à nos journalistes
sur le terrain et c'est le mot c'est la
stupeur ce matin il est il a fait ce
qu'il dit qu'il allait faire il va au
bout de sa logique il va aller chercher
l'ukraine mettre à genoux ce régime
démocratique là et continuer sa voix
sanction pas sanction section par
section et évidemment la question sur
toutes les lèvres présentement
particulièrement en europe c'est de
savoir ce que washington devrait faire
il faut réaliser à quel point même si
évidemment l'administration américaine
ne l'admettra pas à quel point elle est
limitée de façon concrète de façon
politique et de façon économique dans ce
qu'elle peut vraiment faire si on parle
par exemple des sanctions et
l'ambassadeur de kerchove je crois le
sou ni assez bien vers le début
d'émission tantôt la réalité c'est que
si on veut imposer à washington des
sanctions de nature internationale de
concert avec l'europe et on veut le
faire de façon graduelle plus on avance
en sévérité plus on va avancer aussi en
terme de difficultés politiques à garder
un front uni donc oui c'est vrai que
dans les derniers jours on a marqué un
certain coût diplomatique en obtenant
l'accord de l'allemagne de suspendre le
fameux projet de logic nord stream d'une
atteinte à ce qui est vrai c'est que
simultanément en même temps qu'on
obtenait cette concession la de
l'allemand qu'est-ce qui se passe il y
avait des cracks du côté de l'italie où
le premier ministre italien dire vrai
c'est peut-être pas une si bonne idée
que ça de sanctionner la russie surtout
pour ce qui est des questions
énergétiques donc il ya au niveau
international qui va compliquer la donne
pour l'administration baden et au niveau
intérieur simplement à l'intérieur des
états unis là aussi plus on ouvre les on
va vouloir y aller avec des sanctions
musclée plus ça va sans doute requerrait
l'accord du congrès et il n'y a pas de
consensus présentement ça c'est une
chose par rapport aux élus et même par
rapport à la population patrice
considérez ceci gestion on utilise le
mot stupeur je peux être en cause et moi
même avec cette donnée là que je vais
partager sondage publié dans les
derniers jours soit nationale aux états
unis par le magazine d'économistes on
demande aux électeurs républicains aux
états unis est-ce que vous avez une
vision une vision pardon ou une opinion
favorable du président russe ladny
poutine c'est faible d'environ 15 pour
ça qu'ils disent oui mais attachez bien
vos trucs qu'on pose la même question
sujet du président américain c'est 10%
ils répondent oui autrement dit auprès
de l'électorat républicain aux
etats-unis le président russe ait vu de
façon plus favorable que le président
américain le président du parti adverse
donc le les états unis sont tellement
déchiré de l'intérieur que ça aussi ça
va immensément compliquer la tâche de
l'administration byden peu importe à ce
stade si ce qu'elle veut faire court
vraiment contre moscou l' on a parlé
depuis quelques jours dans quelle mesure
le fait que ben laden est affaibli par
un retrait chaotique de l'afghanistan
n'a pas donné un peu un corridor
d'opportunités pour monsieur poutine de
foncer en disant à washington est
affaibli qu'est-ce que peuvent-ils le
faire vraiment contre moi par quelques
sanctions qui vont finir par disparaître
un jour c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas à
l'intérieur du kremlin en même temps
soyons francs le site assez difficile de
pas faire de lien tout au moins leur
hypothétique entre ce qui s'est passé ce
point tournant là je pense qu'il faut
dire pour la présidence byden en août
dernier moment charnière pour sa
présidence d'un point de vue de
politique intérieure parce qu'évidemment
son taux d'approbation a chuté de façon
catastrophique ne s'en est jamais remis
et possiblement oui au niveau
international à cause de ce qu'elle sera
projeté aux adversaires géopolitique des
états unis à commencer par la russie et
et voici ça peut avoir un effet domino
extraordinairement grave potentiellement
c'est clair la russie évidemment au pris
des notes et la dépendance justement de
ce que les états unis peuvent ou
peut-être ne peuvent pas faire face à
cette agression agression la lancée dans
les dernières heures en ukraine fait sûr
et certain qu'on prend des notes
présentement ou en chine et si vous
pensez qu'une invasion de l'ukraine
c'est grave et c'est grave considéré un
instant qu'est ce que ça donnerait comme
dynamique qui sont combinées ça dans
quelques semaines quelques mois à une
invasion chinoise de taïwan on n'est pas
la personne le souhaite il faut réaliser
à quel point on est dans un moment
chargé c'est extraordinairement
dangereux ce qui est en train de se
produire présentement et je vous ai même
pas parlé de ce qui pourrait se passer
dans les autres pays de l'europe
peut-être que vous allez vouloir en
parler là mais c'est qu'on va se
reparler de cet équidé blog mais je
pense que vous mettez le doigt sur
quelque chose d'essentiel depuis ce
matin c'est l' équilibre sécuritaires
non pas seulement européens mais
international qui est vacille
aujourd'hui compte tenu de ce coup de
force de vladimir poutine alors les
conséquences sont nombreux sont
dangereuses évidemment refaite jacob on
se reparle plus tard on va écouter
nadine girola la ministre des affaires
internationales à québec qui a parlé on
écoute ça c'est très court et on revient
et on est vraiment de tout coeur avec
eux on va les supporter à 100%
nomade
sortant en poste au privé d'équipé
québec
écoutez on on a on ne passera pas de ce
côté l'homme ce qu'on veut dire par
contre c'est que on va être très
supporteurs de toutes les mesures qui
vont être prises par le fédéral est on
est on les supporte à 100% dans ce cadre
là vous savez comment qu'on est très
fort au niveau des idées toutes les
valeurs de solidarité des valeurs de
respect du droit international
est ce que le dire pour tina fey
s'initier absolument épouvantable
il y aurait des vins de toute action que
donnerait aux journalistes il a fini à
quelqu'un ça vous maintenir en prison
quand on me demandait secteur
est ce parce que c'est parce que j'ai
dit qu'on voit qu'on voit vraiment
supporter ce que le canada le canada
fait ce que le fédéral fait au niveau de
toutes les mesures jusqu'à 7 points ce
qu'il faut protéger si par exemple donc
on va respecter les décisions que va pas
au gouvernement fédéral jusqu'à quel
point est-ce qu'il faut protéger
l'intégrité du territoire souverain si
le fédéral décide d'intervenir
militairement vous avez d'accord avec ça
nous on va supporter ce que le fédéral
va faire nettement parce que les mesures
les les valeurs de souveraineté c'est
une valeur qui est important ben alors
très importante pour nous c'est une
valeur du droit international et très
digne et bottines ne pas respecter ça
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait
on va effectivement offrir de son
support matériel et on va offrir ouvrir
la porte aus à diriger
le québec qui va a dit nadine giraud
ouvrir ses bas parce qu'il y aura c'est
une évidence des réfugiés ukrainien
après ce coup de force de moscou donc le
québec est prêt à ouvrir ses bras pour
ce qui est de l'autre question gars son
côté
brigadier général à la retraite des
forces canadiennes
quand on pose la question à la ministre
québécoise si le canada va en guerre le
canada n'ira pas en guerre sur le
terrain sur le terrain ukrainien le
canada les hackers sortie ces militaires
d'ukraine ils sont on va ajouter des
militaires en lettonie que frontier
limouxins canadien qu'on avoir lettonie
bien il y avait un groupe de bataille
qui étaient là qui visait justement à
faire un obstacle en fait c'est la
vieille la vieille tactique qu'on avait
tout le temps de la guerre froide c'est
ce qu'on appelle la tactique du trottoir
c'est à dire que si vous attaquez si
vous arrivez sur le territoire lettonie
j'ai pas mal à vous devez vous rendre
compte qu'il ya déjà des membres de
l'otan qui sont là et qui vont à ce
moment là appelé à la rescousse tous les
membres de l'otan d'intervenir selon
l'article simple
g j'ai entendu aussi le monsieur jacob
qui a
finalement ouvert la porte à quelque
chose que je voulais discuter aussi
c'est véritablement que ce que poutine
fait et ce qu'il a dit c'est presque du
copier coller avec le discours qui est
tenu par le président de la chine on
évoque des choses qui datent du 9ème
siècle ou du viiie siècle pour justifier
certaines actions et puis on a
réellement la même chose c'est que on
boude les conventions internationales
dans le code de monsieur poutine c'est
évident avec l'ukraine dans le cas de la
chine basse est évident aussi avec des
pseudos il qui poussent un peu partout
et qui deviennent à ce moment là une
zone économique exclusive et qui
provoque des frictions avec les pays
limitrophes aussi alors oui les
conventions internationales sont
réellement boudé mais quelle est la
capacité matin des des pays occidentaux
de répondre c'est à ces menaces les
sanctions c'est beau écouter est ce
qu'une sanction en papier va arrêter de
bâle la réponse est non alors quelles
sont les sanctions possibles
véritablement qui s'offrent à la
communauté internationale y en a pas
beaucoup et si vous regardez les
sanctions qui ont été les plus élevées
herbe j'aimerais attirer votre attention
sur celle qu'on avait imposé à la libye
parce que kadhafi à l'époque
sanctionnait beaucoup de groupes
terroristes
alors on l'avait réellement ostracisé de
toutes les institutions internationales
sans oublier cependant que lui avait du
pétrole dans son dans sa cour alors on
va donner s'est servi de ça pour amasser
une dette correction une somme
formidable il n'y avait pas de dette
internationale ils ne devaient ils ne
devaient rien à aucune organisation
internationale
il s'est servi de sa finalement pour
relancer son pays et faire d'autres
choses et le risque avec ces sanctions
lorsque tout ou tard elle attaque le
pays qu'on veut sanctionner m la
population bien sûr qu'à ce moment là se
range derrière la reprise et quelle est
l'alternative à son côté quelle est
l'alternative
parce que si
si l'ukraine je le rappelle pour les
gens depuis ce matin faisait partie de
l'otan cessera automatique un pays
membre est amochée et rennes réponse
militaire de l'otan dont un américain
ce n'est pas le cas est ce que l'otan
pourrait décider de façon exceptionnelle
qu'on se mêle et si c'est le cas elle on
imagine en e-mail ont déjà on est dans
un drame l'on serait dans un cauchemar
total
absolument là aussi tout ça pour dire
que finalement il ya très très peu de
moyens et les moyens qu'on en auront un
effet dissuasif à court terme à long
terme je crois pas que ce sera suffisant
alors il va falloir réellement on va
voir toute la panoplie d'outils qui sauf
à la communauté internationale savez il
ya des choses qui existent encore qu'ils
sont tous les jours envoie 100 c'est la
guerre cybernétique ya même pas de
règles internationales qui réglemente
comment peut-on définir par exemple si
on paralyse tout un pays en faisant
guerre cybernétique les banques sont
fermées les tout ce qui est automatique
tout ce qui est informatisé on peut
détruire sa distance et c'est
pratiquement impossible présentement
avec le cadre légal international de
dire nous avons un assaut sur notre pays
et puis il faut avoir des mesures de
rétorsion exact ça c'est là les
nouvelles guerres mais on voit que tu
avec les nouvelles guerres en parallèle
on utilise des moyens très
traditionnelle des chars l'artillerie
qu'elle son côté je vais demander la
carte
rare résumé nous à 9h56 l'opération
jusqu'ici on a attaqué des cibles
militaires des entrepôts de munitions on
a attaqué donc on veut déstabiliser
couper la tête et les moyens militaires
des ukrainiens alors qu'on entre par
ailleurs par le nord par l'ess en char
et par le sud aussi avec les crimes et
avec le personnel qui est débarqué sur
les côtes
l'ukrainien
alors dans le code de l'est mais on voit
un lien qui va se faire entre l'est de
l'ukraine et la région du donbass dans
le nord parce qu'on pourrait voir
réellement ce qu'ils vont cheminer assez
rapidement vers la capitale qui aime qui
est le siège du gouvernement et le
commandement un contrôle aussi des
forces armées ukrainiennes alors c'est
une question de temps avant que les
forces soviétiques puce arrivée faire le
link up faire le lien avec le dôme basse
et encerclé la capitale et ce n'est pas
en fait votre utilisation est
intéressant du mot soviétique parce que
c'est des méthodes
effectivement soviétique et la force de
frappe russe est tellement démesurément
plus grande que celle de l'ukraine
que on comprend très bien l'image de son
côté merci beaucoup on va se reparler
plus tard on suit ça évidemment mesdames
et messieurs de minute en minute je vous
rappelle qu'on a sur le terrain tamare
altérer ce coup du côté russe
on à marie-eve bédard du côté ukrainien
à kiev
ce matin des deux côtés les deux côtés
et du côté russe et du côté ukrainien ça
a été la stupeur de voir que la guerre
se mettait en marche
et que c'était totalement réel pour la
première fois depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale les sirènes ont retenti en
ukraine il faut quand même le faire et
on a connu beaucoup beaucoup de conflits
par ailleurs mais en europe de voir une
attaque de cette ampleur contre compte
une démocratie c'est quelque chose
écoutez
[Musique]
70 installations militaires ont été
attaqués au moins il ya des morts des
décès on n'en parle pas beaucoup depuis
ce matin parce que les bilans on
comprenait sont extrêmement
difficiles à obtenir des deux côtés mais
l'ukraine fait état d'une quarantaine de
décès du côté russe du côté ukrainien on
dit qu'on a abattu qu'on a tué un
certain nombre de soldats russes donc
les bilans vont s'accumuler au cours de
la journée mais ce que l'on sait c'est
que l'infernale machine de guerre russe
est en marche ayant rien pour l'instant
qui n'arrête vladimir poutine je rejoins
à kiev en direct notre camarade
marie-eve bédard marie-eve bonjour et
quelle heure est il chez vous et
meilleure fin de l'après-midi milieu de
l'après midi
il dit c'est un vrai bon alors on s'est
parlé à peu près à une heure et demie
depuis ce moment là qu'est ce que vous
avez pu entendre et voir dans la
capitale
mais les choses bougent assez rapidement
autour de la capitale avant les sirènes
ont retenti à nouveau au cours de
l'après midi il ya eu quelques
explosions autour de la capitale kiev
mais surtout assez récemment il ya moins
d'une heure jeudi on a vu des images de
soldats russes des soldats qui ont été
aéroportée dans l'aéroport dont on
oeuvre qui est juste à l'extérieur de
kiev si on a pu voir sur cnn entre
autres des soldats russes qui disait
avoir pris le contrôle de cet aéroport
là il ya eu des échanges de tirs un peu
avant qu'on voit les images ou les
salles des ukrainiens tentaient de
lancer une contre-offensive pour
reprendre le territoire de cette app de
cet aéroport fait inquiétant aussi le
ministère des affaires intérieures a
annoncé que des unités russes étaient
aux alentours de tchernobyl vous
souviendrez tous de la catastrophe
nucléaire la il ya énormément de déchets
nucléaires qui y sont entreposés le
ministère de l'intérieur qui dit les
soldats sur place font tout pour
empêcher que les soldats russes puissent
prendre le contrôle de tchernobyl mais
qu'une explosion pourrait avoir des
conséquences encore une fois
catastrophique et pas qu en ukraine
mettait des retombées pourraient aller
jusqu au bélarus et jusqu en europe ce
matin à votre heure et vous le disiez
plus tôt il ya des gens qui continuer
parce qu'évidemment on s'y attendait pas
même si on le dit beaucoup on faisait ça
n'arrivera pas or c'est arrivé ce matin
les gens continuaient dans certains cas
à vaquer à leurs occupations l'attention
ça doit être palpable à monter quand
même considérablement
énormément les ukrainiens s'étaient
préparés depuis des semaines depuis des
mois certains en préparant un sac à
attraper au dernier instant avec des
documents en ordre pour pouvoir prendre
la fuite d'autres se sont entraînés au
maniement des armes pour pouvoir
rejoindre les forces de défense
ukrainienne le cas échéant formation de
premiers soins aussi mais n'empêche que
ce discours du président de la dunière
poutine a eu plus que l'effet d'une
douche froide c'était une douche glace
angle pour les gens ici qui avait espéré
jusqu'au dernier instant qu'on pourrait
éviter un conflit d'une telle ampleur
mais les choses se précipitent donc il
ya des gens oui qui cherchent à vaquer à
leurs occupations de façon normale
beaucoup se sont rendus au travail dans
les transports en commun il faut dire
que maintenant le métro dans tous les
avis des autorités ici que ce soit de la
ville de kiev ou de ville à l'extérieur
à kharkhiv c'est la même chose les
stations métro servent d'abri aux gens
quand on entend les sirènes entre autres
pour dire aux gens de se mettre à l'abri
c'est un des endroits qui a été indiquée
pour que les gens puissent aller ce prix
se préserver en cas de frappes aériennes
sur les villes mais bon alors il ya des
gens qui ont choisi de fuir fuir l'est
du pays pour pouvoir se réfugier plus à
l'ouest parce que c'est dans l'est où on
voit ce en ce moment les combats les
plus importants il ya eu des convois
d'évacuation qui ont commencé en milieu
d'après midi diraient certains par
autobus d'autre part très on tente de
maintenir
l'horaire des trains de façon assez
régulière sauf à quelques endroits où
c'est impossible les combats sont trop
importantes donc on a annulé ses
liaisons ferroviaires mais ailleurs
c'est comme ça qu'on fait beaucoup d
évacuation les autorités ukrainiennes
qui ont rompu officiellement à 11h30
heure locale ce matin tout lien
diplomatique avec la russie reproche à
la russie aux forces russes d'avoir
refusé tous les appels qui ont été
lancées par les ukrainiens pour offrir à
tout le moins un corridor sécuritaire
pour procéder à ces évacuations de la
population civile ici à kiev on a vu
toute la journée des bouchons de
circulation assez important les gens qui
tentent de fuir donc sur tous les axes
routiers autour de la capitale ça avance
très très lentement il ya beaucoup plus
de vérification aussi des véhicules des
gens avec les mesures avec la loi
martiale a été imposée maintenant on a
dit à tous ces réservistes qui s'étaient
entraînés si vous êtes est en possession
d'une arme qu'ils avaient maintenant le
droit de la porter avec eux sur eux il
ya tous ces réservistes aussi on en a vu
plusieurs encore aujourd'hui se balader
avec des gros sacs d'équipements pour
aller rejoindre des unités auxquelles
ils ont été convoqués hier avec cet
ordre de rappel d'à peu près de 36000
réservistes dans la ville marie-eve on
le disait on le dit depuis ce matin à
l'aube fait depuis cette nuit ce sont
des cibles militaires essentiellement
qui ont été visés est ce que on est au
courant est ce qu'il ya des bilingues
sont donnés à kiev sur des civils qui
auraient été atteintes
on en a donné quelques uns mais un peu
plus tôt dans la journée ministère de la
défense avait avisé qu'il ne ferait plus
le décompte et qu'il ne donnerait plus
de bilan des pertes à tout le moins deux
militaires pour ce qui est de la
population civile ce sont les
administrations locales qui doivent le
faire au fur et à mesure mais on a
rapporté des frappes sur un hôpital où
il ya plusieurs civils qui auraient été
blessés dans l'est du pays une quinzaine
de personnes ont été blessées au moins
une dizaine de femmes aussi mais tous
ces bilans là sont provisoires donc pour
l'instant assez prématuré d'avancer des
chiffres mais on sait que parmi les
civils il ya des enfants qui ont péri
dans des explosions dans des 1 dans
cette frappe sur un hôpital du personnel
soignant mais aussi de la population
civile qui a été frappé et c'est comme
ça un peu partout les informations sont
contradictoires entre ce que rapporte la
russie est ce que rapportent les forces
du craignent n sûr qu'ils contrôlent
quels secteurs dans le coin d'autres des
sables par exemple il ya une île qui a
été attaqué par des bateaux de la marine
russe ou ensuite les russes auraient
pris le contrôle les ukrainiens
affirment avoir repris le contrôle les
russes contredisent donc tout ça ça va
prendre un certain temps ce pouvoir le
vérifier mais chose certaine c'est que
l'intensité des combats au sol au delà
des bombardements semblent au fur et à
mesure que la journée progresse
s'intensifier aussi et l'objectif on le
rappelle la est clair dans l'esprit de
monsieur poutine c'est de couper la tête
à ce régime ukrainien démocratique et
2es qu'il y aura ensuite occupation paul
on a bien le temps d'en reparler mais
clairement il est à l' attaque pour
démolir cette démocratie ukrainienne
merci beaucoup marie-eve merci fait
attention on vous reparle évidemment je
rappelle aux gens que marié avet en
direct de de kiev et tamar altérer ce qu
entre autres collègues et en direct de
la frontière était à rostov à la
frontière pas très loin de la frontière
ukrainienne
tamara re bonjour
alors choc stupeur on se parlait il ya
une heure et demie du côté ressources il
faut comprendre que des deux côtés il ya
un choc là
où et on a eu le temps de parler avec
des gens maintenant c'est déjà six
heures de l'après midi ici à moscou les
parmi les mots que j'ai entendu c'est
honte on a honte poutine est un assassin
on a peur
la région où on est est une région
stratégique dans la mesure où mon site
une ville frontalière mais les gens sont
au courant de ce qui se passe pour la
simple raison qu'on a d'abord on a fermé
l'espace aérien ici depuis depuis la
nuit avant même que l'invasion commence
le gouverneur a déclaré que toutes les
écoles jusqu'à nouvel an très fermé
parce que dans les villages qui sont un
peu plus loin de nous on est donc où on
a passé beaucoup de temps nous cette
semaine et on a pu constater l'ampleur
de l'arsenal militaire qui se préparait
c'est ce sont des villages qui servent
de point de départ pour des convois
militaires qui sont entrés en ukraine à
belgorod à peu près à 250 kilomètres
c'est un point stratégique à partir
duquel on a même lancé des missiles à
longue portée ça c'était pendant la nuit
j'ai parlé à des gens qui habitent
là-bas parce qu'on était là la semaine
dernière et nous raconte la stupeur avec
laquelle ils vivent non seulement les
les dernières heures mais mais
appréhende les prochaines cetc il ya
beaucoup d'incrédulité
et il faudra voir moi moi je pense que
c'est encore tôt pour saisir l'ampleur
de la réaction des russes mais je viens
de parler à moscou à mon mari entre
autres à des gens et des manifestations
puis ce prêt qui se prépare la selle qui
a organisé la manifestation anti-guerre
pour dénoncer l'invasion de l'ukraine
déjà été arrêtés les quelques
manifestants qui se sont pointés plus
tôt
que l'heure à laquelle ils ont été
convoqués ont déjà été arrêtés aussi
donc sicile et si un mouvement de foule
sur moscou on peut très certainement
s'attendre à ce qu'ils soient réprimés
et déjà des graffitis à l'effigié de
vladimir poutine où on dit qu'il est un
assassin c'est le genre d'ambiance qui à
moscou d'après les gens à qui j'ai parlé
mais ici ici la vie continue un peu
comme comme ça comme si de rien était je
pense les gens comprennent pas encore
l'ampleur parce que sa vie jeu on a la
télé aura six à vingt-quatre qui est des
postes
du kremlin et la façon dont on présente
cette intervention militaire n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'elle est sur le terrain
est ce que vous décris marie-eve on
présente ça comme une intervention
militaire qui était nécessaire pour
sauver des vies et prévenir un massacre
des russes c'est ce que l'animateur un
des animateurs très connu et très
respecté ici a dit ça peut paraître
cynique de parler de missiles mais c'est
nécessaire pour prévenir la vie pour
pour préserver la vie des russes c'est
comme ça que c'est présenté aux russes
qui sont qui sont adeptes de la
télévision d'état ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde c'est pour ça que beaucoup
de stupeur aussi
c'est la réalité même nous comme medias
je pense que c'est un message qui
s'adresse surtout aux médias russes mais
on a tous reçu sur le téléphone ce matin
un message qui s'appelait censure
militaire dans lequel on nous prévient
qu'il faut se fier aux sources
officielles militaires eux seulement
pour rapporter ce qui se passe sur le
terrain en ukraine ou de ce côté-ci de
la frontière par rapport aux activités
de l'armée russe et sa sous peine
d'amendé si on fait de la désinformation
ce que eux considère en tout cas de la
désinformation c'est dans ce contexte là
que la guerre qui se produit chez les
voisins est racontée en russie et
poutine dit que l'opération militaire va
durer aussi longtemps que nécessaire
j'en parlais plus tôt jusqu'à la
décapitation de ce régime démocratique
ukrainienne
oui même s'il a dit hier dans son
allocution que le bull était pote
d'occuper l'ukraine mais de la
démilitarisé
il ira jusqu où il doit aller c'est pas
clair et moi j'ai pas les yeux que marié
bat sur le terrain pour vous parler de
ce qui se passe exactement c'est très
difficile même quand suffit à des
sources militaires ukrainienne qui ont
décidé de pas tout publier le plein à
épeler comme on dit parce que c'est
tellement fou ce qui se passe qu'on peut
pas tenir compte de toute l'activité
militaire mais le porte parole de
vladimir poutine qu'on a entendu deux
fois aujourd'hui dmitri peskov dit deux
choses il dit
d'abord que
moscou était prêt à parler à votre
immense dance qui s'ils étaient prêts à
reconnaître les besoins sécuritaires et
les craintes sécuritaires de moscou on
sait que ça sera jamais le cas et aussi
par rapport aux sanctions qu'on menace
de présenter mais qu'on veut présenter
une question d'heures il dit que je le
sais de la russie va pouvoir survivre à
la réaction émotive
émotive des marchés comme si sa lettre
une vague difficile à passer les toiles
et revenir à la normale
merci tamara passe un message oui alesi
ou alors il ya des députés ukrainiens
qui demande à monsieur zelensky
d'entamer des négociations immédiates
avec la russie
je sais pas si on peut encore parler de
diplomatie à cette heure-ci jld c'est
qu'il va avoir des efforts et des
consultations l'aider réunion d'urgence
de l'otan par rapport à quelle réponse
il faut donner à ce qui se passe en ce
moment mais mais mais kiev a annoncé ce
matin qu on a officiellement rompu les
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
c'est au point mort la russie et
l'ukraine et et sous attaque de la
russie on
a choisi la guerrière les et lundi qui a
tenté de rejoindre le dictateur russe ou
téléphone il ne l'a pas eu il a dit je
n'ai j'étais incapable de parler à
vladimir poutine il ya il espérait un
ultime plaidoyer de son côté alors à
voir mais ce pee wee à les états -
mais il y aura beaucoup d'analystes par
rapport à la valeur et au poids de la
demo de la diplomatie pourquoi elle a
échoué puis je pense qu'à ce stade-ci
quand on voit comment la limite ils se
comportent et les ordres qui le donnait
à son art mais on peut se demander s'il
y avait une chance même que la
diplomatie que ce puisse arrêter éviter
cette catastrophe
tamara rester là je veux poser
exactement cette question vous lisez
dans mes pensées à gérard araud un ex
ambassadeur de france à washington au
conseil de sécurité vous suivez cette
crise mme jarrot depuis depuis
évidemment le début vous êtes vous nous
aviez dit que c'était le discours de
poutine la semaine dernière un délire en
début de la semaine un délire
paranoïaque
est-ce que déjà dans son esprit depuis
très longtemps tout ce ballet
diplomatique dans le fond était inutile
il savait ce qu'il allait faire
vous savez on a découvert à cause des
métadonnées qui ne se sont même pas
qu'ils n'ont même pas essayé d'effacer
que le discours qui là où il annoncé
l'opération militaire avait été
enregistré il y à 48 heures au moment
même où il disait à emmanuel macron
qu'il était prêt à rencontrer by dell
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut
dire très clairement que poutine avait
décidé de conduire une opération
militaire contre contre l'ukraine et que
pourrait pour parler poliment il a
baladé les malheureux chefs d'état
occidentaux que ce soit emmanuel macron
le chancellier sol sous même le
président biden en faisant semblant de
se prêter à une négociation mais sa
décision était visiblement prises et au
fond les américains on n'a pas compris
et c'est et que le nous répéter tous les
jours ils vont attaquer ils vont
attaquer mais cela étant
rétrospectivement leurs informations
étaient justes il avait en effet détecté
que les les russes préparer une
offensive bon quelle est la prochaine
étape parce que là évidemment c'est la
stupeur c'est la condamnation très
agressive en paroles ça sera un autre
une autre vague de sanctions annoncées
mais on a l'impression que l'europe et
les américains ont les mains liées là on
est on est impuissant oui on est un peu
impuissant et aux balcons 1 étant donné
que voilà nos opinions publiques étant
ce qu'elles sont on ne va pas mourir
pour l'ukraine et or la russie à une
supériorité écrasante vis-à-vis de
l'ukraine et il est tout à fait possible
qu en une ou deux semaines les russes
soit à kiev ce qui voudrait dire qu'ils
installeraient évidemment une
marionnette au pouvoir et et nous du
côté européen les américains nous allons
sanctionner mais les sanctions ça n'a
pas fischer changer la politique la
politique russe dont je dirais que nous
sommes en train comme il est arrivé dans
les années 30 dans d'autres occasions
nous sommes en train d'abandonner je le
crains un peu l'ukraine à son sort et si
nous ne voulions pas là-bas donné
le prix serait
épouvantablement élevé ça serait un
conflit armé ça serait ont confirmé ce
serait envoyer nos soldats au sol en
ukraine ce serait une guerre une guerre
au sol en ukraine alors bon en plus vous
savez que poutine nous a menacé
implicitement de l'arme nucléaire mais
enfin l'art nucléaire mots si on les a
donc la dissuasion jouer mais ce serait
des soldats se battant au sol et les
opinions publiques européennes et
américaines y sont absolument pas prête
je voyais un sondage qui disait pour la
france que 70% des français et contre
toute participation toute participation
au conflit donc une fois que l'ukraine
sera dirigé par un gouvernement pro
russe on peut imaginer une fois que le
temps a passé une fois que les européens
en france en allemagne ailleurs auront
encore besoin du gaz russe on va
regarder ça dans un an dit en bon ben il
a fait une bouchée de l'ukraine il a
anéanti une démocratie puis on est resté
impuissant
oui non mais je vous avais non on n'en
est pas là on en est simplement aux
premières 24 heures du conflit donc là
vous sautez pas mal pas mal d'états donc
pour le moment votre vote ce scénario
est d'ailleurs tout à ferait tout à fait
vraisemblable est tout à fait crédible
tout au moins mais pour le moment
essayons de faire au mieux donc des
sanctions des sanctions très forte mais
cela veut dire aussi que l'on rentre
dans une période prolongée de conflit
avec la russie de confrontation si elle
n'est pas armée mais néanmoins deux
confrontations en rideau de fer est en
train de retomber en europe donc à part
les sanctions il faut aussi que nous
préparions c'est à dire améliorer les
capacités militaires européennes qui
sont dont certains pays particulièrement
déficiente mais aussi défendre nos
systèmes informatiques
c'est-à-dire rentrer dans une
confrontation de long terme avec une
russie pécule russie hostile
gérard parlez moi du rôle que pourra que
peugeot est déjà la chaîne qui est un
allié de monsieur poutine la chine
d'abord elle se doit se féliciter du
conflit parce que d'abord cela veut dire
que les américains qui voulait
concentrer toutes leurs énergies sur
l'asie vont devoir en réalité également
s'occuper de l'europe et deuxièmement
cela veut dire aussi que la russie sera
particulièrement dépendante de la chine
donc je dirais que de ce point de vue là
la chine ce n'est pas une mauvaise
affaire ensuite il va falloir c'est un
peu embarrassant c'est la gestion je
dirais quotidienne de la crise parce
qu'elle ne peut pas elle ne peut pas
approuver
l'opération russe qui est quand même
l'invasion d'un pays et d'un pays
étranger mais elle ne va pas sans s'en
dissocier non non plus et donc après ce
que je lisais en ce qui concerne la les
consignes données à la censure en chine
les consignes étaient hier ne pas
critiquer la russie ne pas soutenir
l'occident
ce qui est donc à quelque chose
tellement négatif et je pense que la
chine s'en tiendra là avec vous savez
les mots à la chinoise appelant les
parties à la négociation à l'entente etc
mais elle n'ira pas aux émirats pas au
delà ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
vous êtes gérard araud habitués aux
joutes diplomatiques a analysé la
géopolitique serein plan plus humain sur
un peuple quand vous avez vu ce matin
quand vous vous êtes levés à votre heure
vous avez vu ça ces images ces premières
images que vous avez constaté que la
machine avant c'est la machine russe
avancer vos premiers sentiments
vous savez moi je suis je suis née huit
ans après la seconde guerre mondiale et
comme tout européen en tout cas j'ai été
élevé excusez moi dans les souvenirs
dans des de la guerre de l'occupation et
dont voir des des européens en 2001 de
ce s'abriter dans les couloirs de métro
comme mes grands-parents le faisait
pendant la guerre c'est quelque chose
d'ahurissant vous avez vraiment
l'impression que nous entrons dans une
nouvelle ère nous avons l'impression que
la guerre est de retour il ya eu la
guerre en yougoslavie naturellement mais
là c'est la guerre à l'ancienne
entre guillemets c'est à dire un pays
qui attaque un autre l'europe n'avait
plus connu ça maintenant depuis 1945 et
donc c'était une impression évidemment-
immense tristesse et puis de penser
aussi aux civils qui sont qui sont
piégés par par cette guerre
gérard araud merci beaucoup comme
d'habitude merci à très bien le gros et
au revoir
on va refaire donc on va refaire le fil
de ce qui est arrivé depuis cette nuit
j'en fais les pieds aux encore une fois
c'est très difficile on n'a pas des
bilans très précis c'est normal on est
dans le brouillard de ses premiers
moments ce que l'on sait par contre
c'est que la russie a attaqué une
centaine eu peu moins de cibles
militaires ukrainienne et que les chars
entrent est sud et nord oui c'est ça les
derniers bilans nous proviennent de la
russie des bilans de l'offensive et
qu'il mène en sol ukrainien dont vous le
voyez ça c'est l'aéroport de mario paul
pas très loin de la ligne de front du
donbass on l'oubli presque le dôme bas
ce qui est au coeur de cette lutte là
parce qu'aujourd'hui les attaques sont
sur l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien
la russie dit avoir atteinte et mis hors
service 74 installations militaires or
seul du côté ukrainien et sur ces 74
installation il ya 11 0 arrêt aux
aérodromes comme celui de mario paul qui
ont été atteints les cibles primaires
c'est justement de clouer au sol la
force aérienne de l'ukraine maintenant
je vous fais le rapidement le tour de la
carte vous voyez ça c'est toutes les
grandes villes où il ya eu des
bombardements depuis la soirée ya
première salve de bombardements soirée
ensuite tôt ce matin notre heure locale
il ya eu une deuxième vague de
bombardements qui ont touché pieve qui
ont touché la deuxième ville en
importance du pays aussi kharkiv à
odessa on parle de 18 morts dans les
bombardements 6a brovary a tchernobyl on
nous indique qu'il ya des combats qui
ont commencé dès trop poreuse qui ont
descendu du bélarus alors des combats
qui ont lieu pas très loin de dépôt
nucléaire d'accord d'ailleurs donc pour
le moment pas d'information à savoir
s'il ya un danger à ce sujet là mais ça
demeure néanmoins inquiétants maintenant
il ya aussi un navire turc qui a été
atteint par un missile il n'y a pas eu
de blessés le navire s'est donc ensuite
dirigé vers la roumanie aussi vous le
voyez les russes cible principalement
les installations militaires ici en
hausse et le siège du renseignement
ukrainien qui a été atteinte par les
bombardements c'étaient les premières
attaques du côté de la russie celle-ci
vous le voyez très bien sur ces images
les missiles frappe et cause
d'importantes explosions alors du côté
de l'ukraine tôt ce matin on nous
parlait déjà de 40 soldats morts au
combat il ya de fortes chances que ce
bilan soit à la hausse parce que eu
plusieurs nouvelles scènes qui sont
entre en scène où il ya des d'importants
combats récemment alors vous voyez aussi
les explosions qui ont eu lieu du côté
de la russie selon l'ukraine il ya une
cinquantaine de soldats russes qui
auraient été touchés il ya ces savions
qu'ils auraient été abattus et une école
un hélicoptère aussi qui aurait été
atteint par les défensives l'ukrainienne
maintenant il n'ya pas que les
militaires qui sont touchés par ce qui
se passe des civils au moins dix ans
deux civils sont morts sur l'ukraine
vous voyez très bien des personnes qui
ont été gravement blessées dans ces
bombardements qui ont cours depuis hier
soir et puis les familles ce qu'elles
font et trouve refuge comme elles
peuvent plusieurs se sont réfugiés dans
le métro à kiev avec leurs enfants dans
l'espoir de pouvoir les mettre en
sécurité ça fait un peu et qu est-ce que
monsieur arrow disais précédemment d'une
époque où en france pendant la guerre on
se cachait dans le métro pour se mettre
à l'abri c'est exactement ce qui est en
cours présentement qui avant une crème
très clair résumé merci beaucoup et bien
sûr quant au fur et à mesure on va
préciser
l'ampleur de cette attaque russe sur
l'ukraine gérald les marchés ma vie la
marge pour les marchés c'est un
cauchemar oui on on mesure pas encore
bien sur l'ampleur de ce que ça veut
dire sur l'économie mondiale sur les
flux financier sur les déplacements de
capitaux on sait qu'il ya des sanctions
économiques qui ont été imposées contre
les banques russes on sait également
qu'il ya une suspension de la
certification de cette canalisation de
gaz naturel qui devaient entrer en
fonctions un peu plus tard cette année
en partance de la russie jusqu'à
l'allemagne c'est ce que nous savons
pour l'instant mais jusqu'où iront les
sanctions et jusqu'où ça va ébranler
l'économie mondiale pour l'instant je
vous dirais que la chute boursière est
relativement mesurés 650 points 750
points qu'on voyait un peu plus tôt et
même 800 points pour le dow jones à un
certain moment on a vu pire au début
notamment de la pandémie donc c'est
relativement mesurée mais depuis le
début de l'année les marchés sont quand
même un recul de 10 à 15 % donc une
forme d'incertitude donc new york est en
baisse de 2 et demi pour cent toronto
perd approximativement 1 1/2 %
présentement à francfort reculent de 5%
à paris 4 % donc des reculs quand même
somme toutes marques et aux des
ressources en retour et c'est ça qui est
le plus important aujourd'hui c'est la
hausse du prix du pétrole le pétrole
brent a atteint la barre des 105 dollars
105 dollars le baril et plus de 100
dollars aux etats unis pas triste un
prix du litre d'essence qui va monter à
1 $ 80 le litre probablement
possiblement dans les prochains jours 8
% d'augmentation pour les prix du
pétrole
prix de l'or valeur refuge en temps
d'incertitudes grimpent de deux et demi
à 3% on était à 1964 dollars il ya pas
très longtemps il ya quelques minutes on
s'approche de la barre des 2000 dollars
ce qui serait un record dans l'histoire
de l'or et le gaz naturel le prix que je
vous ai mis c'est le prix en europe 41 %
d'augmentation
il ya déjà un prix du gaz naturel qui
augmente de 300% depuis le depuis un an
en europe présentement pourquoi parce
que 40% du gaz naturel d'europe vient de
russie et le tiers du gaz naturel
exportés par la russie vers l'europe
passe par l'ukraine et 25% du pétrole
d'europe viennent la russie la russie
deuxième exportateur producteurs du
monde de gaz naturel et troisième pour
ce qui est du pétrole un des plus
importants producteurs de grains du
monde également donc comme je vous dis
il ya des éléments économiques
importants dans l'échiquier compte tenu
de l'importance de la russie dans la
production qui pourrait avoir un impact
économique important et je reviens à ce
qu'on disait beaucoup plus tôt
avec une analyse d'un des invités si
l'occident n'est pas prêt ce que les
sanctions qui seront annoncés la cascade
qui vont s'accumuler aujourd'hui de
sanction si on n'est pas prêt ce que ça
fasse mal à nous prix du pétrole entre
aux approvisionnements en gaz
en europe ça ne sera pas efficace alors
on doit s'attendre à ce qu'on le voit
très clairement qu'on le centre ou si la
sanction exactement vous avez tout à
fait raison parce que les sanctions
économiques qu'on n'impose à la russie
ont pour objectif de déstabiliser la
russie bien bien évidemment sur le plan
financier sur le plan économique mais
nous avons un impact il y a un impact
parce que l'europe surtout est
dépendante de l'énergie russe et
l'allemagne notamment les pays bas entre
autres l'énergie russe est absolument
capital et durant la guerre froide
l'allemagne et la russie l'union
soviétique ont négocié des accords pour
le transport de gaz naturel donc north
stream et nord stream 2 c'est incarne en
quelque sorte la canalisation qui passe
sous la mer incarne en quelque sorte ce
lien absolument essentiel énergétique je
vais vous montrer l'effondrement du
marché russe alors ça c'est peut-être un
impact pour l'instant monsieur poutine
ne semble pas très sensible à tout ce
qui se passe sur le plan économique il
ya toutes les sanctions mais la bourse
s'effondre en russie à moscou
aujourd'hui l' indice principal qu'on
appelle l'indicé rts a chuté de 40 à 45%
c'est 260 milliards de dollars de valeur
boursière qui se sont effondrés et la
sberbank
la sberbank l'une des plus grandes
banques de russie perd 50% sur les
marchés aujourd'hui la caisse de dépôt
et placement du québec qui incidemment
présente ses résultats financiers
aujourd'hui détenait des avoirs dans la
sberbank ont appris hier que la caisse
avait vendu ses actions sans doute au
bon moment sachant ce qui allait se
produire gazprom qui est la société
publique énergétiques de russie perd 40%
sur les marchés présentement donc à
court terme laon le l'impact est
puissant sur le marché financier russe
gérald on va se reparler merci beaucoup
le dha merci beaucoup à plus tard
générale claudine richard ottawa il ya
des ukrainiens au canada qui s'inquiète
le mot est faible
oui et nous on a décidé de se déplacer
devant l'ambassade de la russie pour
voir un peu ce qui se passe je serai
qu'un très petit groupe de gens qui
s'est rassemblée ici on a vu aussi des
gens passaient devant les caméras de
l'ambassade avec le doigt d'honneur mais
quelques gens qui commencent à se
rassembler avec des affiches qui demande
l'emprisonnement de vladimir poutine
donc il ya même chose qui s'est passé
hier soir mais c'est très limité comme
mouvement mais lorsqu'on leur parle
assez ukrainien au canada on sent
vraiment l'inquiétude y en a plusieurs
qui n'ont pas fermé les yeux de la nuit
après qu'on ait eu assez bon peu vu ces
bombardements et ils s'inquiètent
pourquoi bien parce qu'ils savent la
puissance militaire de la russie ils
savent aussi que les ukrainiens en ce
moment contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser bien son pesant de position
défaitiste
ils sont prêts à se battre nous dit on
et on s'inquiète sur des résultats que
ça va donner sur le terrain parce qu'il
ya plusieurs de ces ukrainiens canadiens
qui ont de la famille dans les régions
qui ont été bombardés je vous invite à
écouter on trouve un de ceux ci qui
était très émotif lorsqu'on lui parlait
de ce qui se passe en fait en ce moment
chez lui
je suis sûr que l'ukraine
va continuer à
lutter contre la pollution et en mon
avis c'est peut-être un
missile nucléaire qui pourrait arrêter
la résistance
très bien oui oui ça
excusez moi c'est qu'on en parlait
d'autre chose c'est sarah schmocker
évidemment oui en passant la santé
publique d'ottawa et s'est adressé
directement aux ukrainiens pour ceux qui
ont besoin on est et on a été vraiment
proactif donc on a dit si vous
connaissez des gens qui sont touchés par
cette situation assurez-vous au cours
des prochains jours les appelait les
textes et de rester en contact parce que
la couverture internationale bon de
cette crise risque d'être bien
bouleversante pour ces gens là et je
m'en voudrais de mentionner baic et des
gens qui sont tout simplement
bouleversée de voir l'ue la russie
envahir leur payer mais il ya aussi des
ukrainiens qui se disent en quelque
sorte peu surpris de la situation même
déçu que les efforts diplomatiques est
échoué c'est le cas entre autres de cet
autre ukrainienne qui obéit
être aussi réaliste le crâne est à côté
d'un éléphant qui est leur réussit si on
regarde si on met un pas vers l'arrière
de mon regard de la politique
extérieure du commandant et s'aligne pas
mal avec la politique extérieure des
états unis craignent la tragédie c'est
l'histoire de l'incapacité de du lait de
chèvre du pays de l'otan dans ces deux
zones
maintenir cet équilibre est très fragile
entre l'occident et la russie
alors nous on reste sur place devant
l'ambassade la russie à ottawa on voit
bon certains craignent un qui se sont
rassemblés siens dire de l'autre côté du
trottoir la police est venue les voir le
pour s'assurer que ça reste bien
pacifique qui le tout ce très petit
groupe on verra si au cours de la
journée car en plus grand rassemblement
merci claude yen à plus tard où va se
rendent en ukraine en direct par les
romains nwachukwu et ancien ambassadeur
canadien en ukraine nous avait en poche
je crois jusqu'en 2019 vous êtes elles
vivent ça c'est dans l'ouest la ville où
on avait déplacé l'ambassade canadienne
avant de la fermer il ya quelques heures
donc à lever vous serez de la plus la
frontière polonaise alors que comment
comment vous avez d'abord vécu c'est
cette journée hallucinant
j'ai pas dormi je dois dire en ancien
des unités du crise d'une autre
ministère d'espèces étrangères j j'ai
senti que ça vienne un jeu les suivis
[Musique]
je je je me considère réaliste quelques
qui se préparent pour des pires
scénarios mais ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
c'était même plus intense que j'aurais
pu imaginer
la géographie étendue des freins est
rien c'est du jamais vu je pense
depuis des décennies en europe
vous avez raison de le souligner c'est
du jamais vu depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale romane huacho qu'à partir de là
est ce que vous croyez que monsieur
poutine va se contenter de d'un
changement de régime plus poreuse donc
d'engagement de ne jamais entrer dans le
temps pour ce qui est de l'ukraine et il
va se retirer pour les ukrainiens
comment vous voyez la suite
je vois un cil
je dirais l'armée ukrainienne continue à
se battre alors c'est pas du tout décidé
le sort du pays et chaque soutien c'est
très actuel pour les ukrainiens
maintenant mais si monsieur poutine
pourrait faire tout ce qu'il voudrait
on aurait une espèce de
[Musique]
purification pays c'est à dire tout le
monde qui est trop libéral trop
démocratique trop nationaliste
serré
purger
et je sais pas bannies ou emprisonnés
et c'est ça qui est vraiment effrayant
parce qu'il ya une vision
[Musique]
impérialistes derrière tout ça c'est pas
simplement le problème avec un voisin
monsieur watch vous tous vous soulignez
quelque chose de très important bien sûr
l'analyse géopolitique est important on
a beaucoup dit on a beaucoup expliquer
aux gens que monsieur poutine ne pouvait
tolérer
la possibilité que l'ukraine fasse
partie de l'otan ses portes aux quais
une présence militaire de l'ouest de
l'otan à côté de moscou dans le berceau
dans son esprit le berceau de la
civilisation russe kiev or vous touchez
un point extrêmement important la menace
ou six pour monsieur poutine c'est le
régime
démocratique de l'ukraine à ses portes
exactement et
pour lui
qui est devenu dictateur on l'a vu
lundi quand il a
parler avec son
son gang des agents de sécurité eux
et le fait que lui il a développé toute
une idéologie
qui revient ou
aux arts les plus réactionnaires comme
nicolas le premier
où il est le gendarme de la russie mais
il veut aussi être gendarme de toute
l'europe
monsieur watchou vous avez été
ambassadeur je le disais qu'est ce qu'il
reste comme possibilité à l'europe au
canada aux états unis bon il y aura des
sanctions mais qu'elle préfère
des sanctions faux faux pas encore une
fois faut faire des demi-mesures ans ça
pourrait nuire au pauvre peuple russe
enfin le peuple russe n'a pas beaucoup à
dire dans tout ça et il faut frapper le
régime pour le faire ressentir pour
l'élite mais aussi pour pour la
population qui pourraient se poser la
question est ce que eux les russes
doivent tolérer un tel régime wade
on va suivre ça merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé elle veut en direct de
l'ukraine monsieur watchou qu on se
reparlera certainement merci beaucoup
très apprécié merci au revoir
afin de jacob alors
on le disait
marie-eve le disais à tchernobyl
qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire on peut en
dire est que le président ukrainien est
en train essentiellement d'amener de son
côté des alliés européens plutôt moins
ce qu'il voudrait avoir comme alliés
européens parce que ce qu'il dit c'est
que les russes tentent présentement
activement de prendre le contrôle la
station de plus tôt dans la région de
tchernobyl et que ça pourrait avoir des
répercussions de point de vue sécurité
si évidemment il y avait une sorte de
désastre nucléaire évidemment qu'ils
seraient pas comparables à ceux conduits
dans les années 80 la danse en termes de
débit nucléaire que ça pourrait aller
bien au delà du territoire ukrainien
dont qui les interpelle c'est une façon
pour lui d' interpeller d'autres pays
européens et d'essayer de leur mettre la
pression pour qu'il essentiellement veut
bien donner de l'appui plus directe à
l'ukraine et vous voyez là d'amatrices
une illustration parmi plusieurs du
danger énorme de ce conflit là n'est pas
seulement question de deux pays et pas
seulement question de la russie et de
l'ukraine en fait il ya une chose qui si
je ne m'abuse après été mentionné depuis
début de l'émission tantôt qui je crois
mérite d'être mentionné c'est que déjà
depuis hier on a trois pays sont
essentiellement en gare il ya aussi le
bélarus qui est vraiment un pays
limitrophe à la fois pour la russie et
l'ukraine et qui a activement et dès
avant les vals l'évasion de l'ukraine la
russie à faire des exercices militaires
et qui depuis hier a carrément permis à
la russie d'utiliser sa frontière pour
y aller de façon offensive en ukraine
donc on a déjà trois pays activement
impliqués et on en a au moins quatre
autres qui font partie de l'otan
notamment l'espagne et la lettonie la
lituanie qui ont demandé la pologne qui
ont demandé une rencontre d'urgence on
sait de l'otan pour invoquer l'article 4
qui ne mènent pas nécessairement
heureusement là à ce que le temps en
bacs d'un conflit mais qui fait
augmenter de façon substantielle le
niveau de risque et le niveau de tension
donc quand on dit qu'il n'ya pas de
scénario où la dynamique comparable à ce
qu'on voit maintenant depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale c'est pas pour rien
évidemment qui en a eu d'autres conflits
mais pas de conflit où le risque de
débordements étaient aussi grave ait
aussi un partant qu'est-ce qu'on a
présentement que dira d'après vous
monsieur baden bon condamnation
extrêmement sévère évidemment mais
monsieur baden qui parle on le voit à
12h30 que jusqu'où peut-il aller
et il imagine que seul le temps nous le
dira en même temps soyons très très
clairs une des options les plus
évidentes qui a été discuté c'est
d'envoyer de l'aide directe le militaire
sur le terrain autrement dit redéployer
des sud-américains et ce à la maison
blanche a été catégorique depuis des
semaines depuis le tout début de cette
crise là c'est à deux questions donc je
serais personnellement extrêmement
surpris devant le président changé son
discours là dessus donc qu'est-ce qu'il
peut vraiment faire de sa vie un petit
peu la conversation qu'on avait tantôt
ensemble c'est à dire qu'il reste là
pour l'instant la question des sanctions
première de punir le régime poutine de
façon beaucoup plus musclée que ce qui
était fait jusqu'à maintenant au-delà de
cela dans peut-être le plus moyen terme
il y aurait évidemment la question d'une
éventuelle insurrection qui pourrait
financé par les américains ça c'est une
idée par donc été évoqué par différents
élus au congrès au courant des dernières
semaines si particulièrement s'il y a
aucune passion russe parce qu'il faut
réaliser que on parlera des conséquences
pour les occidentaux pour les ukrainiens
il ya dans tout seul dans tout ça toute
cette opération là un risque
potentiellement énormes pour vladimir
poutine et son gouvernement également
justement s'il ya occupation le
président russe je crois est assez
familier avec l'histoire de son propre
pays pour savoir que la à la fois la
chute du régent régime tsariste il ya de
cela un peu plus d'un siècle et
évidemment la chute de l'union
soviétique avait essentiellement je
simplifie la met à l'heure car comme
facteur extrêmement important d un
glissement
militaires à l'étranger donc si on peu
compliqué sur le terrain la tâche des
troupes russes via le financement d'une
insurrection ça pourrait également une
autre avenue pour les américains même si
évidemment elle s'accompagnerait de
coûts humains potentiellement
catastrophiques pour les ukrainiens
parce qu'on avait un conflit civil
évidemment sur le terrain en ukraine qui
pourrait durer pendant cette manne
longtemps raphaël merci on va suivre
bien sûr ensemble cette déclaration de
publiques de monsieur byden un peu plus
tard en tout début d'après-midi gaston
côté qui est toujours avec nous
brigadier général à la retraite des
forces canadiennes qu'elles sont côtés
pour vous nous résumer parce que
beaucoup de gens n'étaient pas avec nous
dès le début de l'émission on a assisté
à quel genre d'offensive militaire
jusqu'ici
c'est la neutralisation en fait des
systèmes de contrôle
neutralisation aussi des dépôts de
munitions justement afin de
diminuer la capacité de riposte de des
forces armées ukrainiennes alors ça
c'est accompagnée évidemment par le
ciblage des aéroports qui évidemment
pour cette tous des systèmes de radar et
on être neutralisés ce système là en
plus évidemment de trouver les endroits
où il y avait des postes comme un
contrôle c'est la céréale madisons la
liste de ces cas c'est pour ce genre
d'opération lassé de neutraliser
finalement tous ceux qui peuvent
interférer avec l'opération avait aussi
et continue des fachos those who elysées
oui
évidemment ce qu'on a appris aussi c'est
qu'il y avait le centre du renseignement
qui se tiennent pas tellement loin du de
basket attaqué par des missiles alors se
faire et elle mal au parti de la liste
de ces comme je disais là pour une
opération qui a c'est que de gens là et
compte tenu des forces en présence
comment vous voyez la suite des choses
dont l'artillerie a été très importante
soit dr soit des deux canons il ya des
chars déjà entré comment vous voyez la
suite
de la suite évidemment ce qu'on ne sait
pas jusqu'à présent c'est jusqu'à quel
point l'armée ukrainienne est en mesure
de répondre à cette agression dont on a
très peu d'informations sur le terrain
de sorte qu'il est très difficile de
savoir si
la vareuse peut-être retarder vous peut
simplement est arrêté sur un obstacle
pour beaucoup d'obstacles naturels
on passe alors ça ne ralentira pas
davantage
l'avancée russe ce qui est intéressant
de noter par 40 ou ce qui est important
aussi c'est qu'il y aurait des troupes
qui ont été
déposés sous l'aéroport tout près de
kiev alors éventuellement c'est trop
pleuvront prend le contrôle l'aéroport
ont pu éventuellement vont probablement
fait pardon un lien avec des troupes qui
viennent soit du sud ou bien de l'est
pour finalement s'en aller jusqu'au
centre du gouvernement ukrainien
on pourrait penser
que monsieur poutine en mer en forçant
genou à terre du régime ukrainien
demande des concessions au parlement
ukrainien au pead ukraine concernant des
promesses sur le temps de ne jamais même
y penser de ne jamais accepter des
troupes sur le territoire etc on prépare
ans et qui aurait peut-être une voie de
sortie après une première étape mais
c'est la version optimiste ça mes côtés
durant toutes les délibérations
diplomatique eu lieu entre les états
unis et la russie les états-unis ont
tour est inflexible at dans ce sens que
on a on n'enlèvera pas l'option
d'inclure l'ukraine dans l'otan alors
dès le départ se situe pas mal le débat
est ce que vous voulez monsieur poutine
s'était véritablement d'un pas avoir le
lota à ses portes c'est clair que quand
vous regardez la carte de l'europe et
vous voyez tout le bleu d'aider des pays
qui font maintenant partie de l'otan ben
c'est sûr que pour quelqu'un qui est
paranoïaque le moindre mal on voit que
celle réellement de plus en plus un
geste courageux de la russie
effectivement alors c'est ça qui
véritablement et la cause ou de de la
panique ou de la paranoïa finalement du
président poutine et qui plus est
maintenant on parle de deux pays qui
commence à discuter fermement pour la
possibilité de devenir la possibilité
d'entrer dans l'otan on parle de la
suède est là hollande alors
véritablement long compléterait un peu
de choses près le cirque le mans de tout
ce qui était la sienne l'ancien rideau
de fer finalement qui serait rendue plus
que oui hélas ce qui est la seule chose
qui qui qui arrêtaient finalement
c'est l'expansion c'était l'ukraine et
le bélarus maintenant bélarus évidemment
à l'inter nous ont beaucoup de problèmes
à mater finalement l'opposition
éventuellement ça va peut-être se
retourner contre le gouvernement du
bélarus et juste pour renchérir sur ce
que monsieur jacob disait bien
effectivement si on accepte des troupes
qui vont participer à un combat on
devient partie prenante du conflit comme
tel alors elle peut pas s'en échapper en
disant comme ce matin on disait que le
président a de la biélorussie disait que
ce n'était pas si troupe qui entrait
dans le territoire ukrainien c'est
dommage mais il est partie prenante du
conflit maintenant oui mais lui il n'y a
pas de secret là qui sont un non pas
alain biya meilleur de la fédération
mais il son ami ami avec avec monsieur
poutine joe revient sur le départ le
même si on est loin de là mais le départ
on vient d'en parler de l'otan ce qu'il
y aurait pas eu moyen pour le temps de
dire d'ailleurs le chancelier allemand
proposait un peu cette solution désir de
toute façon c'est pas dans les plans à
court terme on peut ne peut pas tant
parce qu'on peut pas développer une
petite phrase qui fera l affaire du
petit nazza ça arrivera pas d'ici 15 à
20 ans
ça a été discuté ça a été mais encore
une fois vous savez à l'intérieur de
l'otan il ya deux voix une voix très
forte qui est celle des états unis et
une voix un peu plus faible que celle de
l'europe et par un peu par cynisme est
un peu à la blague on a toujours dit que
le but de l'ôta c'est de garder les
états unis en europe gardez la russie
loin de nous et garder l'allemagne
faible alors présentement c'est pas mal
finalement ça résume un peu la
solidarité de l'ôta lorsqu'on fait appel
à tous les pays de l'otan pour une
mission comme celle de l'afghanistan
elle vous assure de quelque chose c'est
que les pays de l'otan qui vont se
déployer des troupes
quelques fois c'est l'autre ne sont pas
prêtes à combattre leur parle mais leur
a interdit de combattre leur parlement
lors mais tellement de restriction quand
je demande pourquoi ils sont déployés
alors ce n'est pas dix ans comme les
pays plus classiques comme la france la
grande bretagne les états unis le canada
qui ont fait grandement leur part
certains des pays en fait qui ont laissé
leur défense nationale plus ou moins
désuétude alors ce pas nécessairement
des des partenaires fiables bon pour
l'aide parce que depuis quelques jours
le président craignait demande de l'aide
militaire à l'otan le non seulement du
matériel et de l'aide c'est inimaginable
on ne pense pas envoyé aucun soldat
aucune attaque aérienne par exemple qui
proviendraient de l'otan
écoutez je vais juste me fiais la loi
internationale en théorie
la possibilité serait que l'onu
comment d'une opération d'imposition de
la paix dans ce secteur maintenant
regardez le scénario on sera en conseil
de sécurité et puis là où vous avez au
moins deux pays
quand le droit de veto la chine et la
russie alors tout de suite le mandat ne
serait pas faisable alors
automatiquement il faudrait contourner à
la fois les règlements de l'onu et les
règlements de l'otan semble
donc toute riposte militaire coordonnée
de l'ouest et
n'est pas envisageable
c'est pas envisageable sauf qu'encore
une fois traditionnellement dans
plusieurs pays ce qui s'est passé c'est
que il ya effectivement la possibilité
d'avoir une guérilla qui peut
s'organiser à l'intérieur du pays
surtout si la russie décide d'y laisser
une occupation alors c'est sûr qu'à ce
moment là deviennent une cible plus ou
moins statique
une armée d'occupation à des problèmes
qui existent c'est l'ennui qui en les
militaires parce que ça devient
extrêmement routinier d'être là c'est
pas comme de l'action durant un assaut
alors
historiquement et fatalement c'est
gerber d'occupation ne devienne le
fragile deviennent aussi des bonnes
cibles pour tout groupe de guérilla quel
engrenage quand même quel engrenage
merci beaucoup à plus tard raphaël
bouvier au clair à paris chez vous le
président français a dit ce matin nous
sommes aux côtés de l'ue crainte est un
acte de guerre nous serons côté du crin
un poids politique bien sûr et non pas
militaire vous l'utilisez
oui bien qu'il a utilisé le terme
militaire tout comme boris johnson le
premier ministre du royaume uni on se
demandait comment l'utilisation de ce
terme là puissent concrétiser compte
tenu de tous les facteurs que vous venez
d'aborder dans le cadre de cette
entrevue mais clairement il ya un appui
symbolique politique également que la
france le royaume uni entre autres et
d'autres pays du continent européen veut
le démontrer à l'endroit de l'ukraine
parce que monsieur macron l'a souligné
dans son discours mais aussi boris
johnson il ne s'agit pas seulement d'une
attaque contre l'ukraine ils ont
beaucoup utilisé les mots attaque contre
la démocratie en ukraine et attaques
contre le continent européen évidemment
compte tenu de la proximité de ce qui se
passe en ce moment avec l'europe de
l'ouest il ya énormément d'inquiétude
dans les capitales occidentales écouter
d'ailleurs le ton emprunté par par le
président maquereau
en refusant la voie diplomatique en
choisissant la guerre le président
poutine n'a pas seulement attaquée
l'ukraine il a décidé de bafouer la
souveraineté
de l'ukraine il a décidé de porter la
teinte la plus grave à la paix à la
stabilité dans notre europe depuis des
décennies
l'union européenne promet d'ailleurs
raphaël des sanctions sans précédent at
on dit
là on attend dans les prochaines minutes
les sanctions du royaume uni boris
johnson doit prendre la parole devant le
parlement à londres et puis ici côté
européen bien il ya eu des négociations
des tractations tout au cours de la
journée entre les ambassadeurs des 27
pays membres et ce soir on a convoqué
les dirigeants des 27 pays pour avaliser
confirmé ces sanctions il ya déjà des
sanctions qui ont été annoncées plus tôt
cette semaine ont ciblé entre autres des
institutions financières bancaires
russes ont ciblé aussi des élus élus du
parlement russe qui ont appuyé la
déclaration d'indépendance par vladimir
poutine des deux territoires de l'est de
l'ukraine mais aussi des proches du
président russe ella on dit qu'on va
annoncer
d'importantes sanctions les plus sévères
quand on jamais imposé les membres de
l'union européenne à l'envers dans le
détail ce que c'est il y aura rencontre
ce soir ce qu'on dit aussi c'est qu'on
évalue également des sanctions contre la
biélorussie patrice évidemment
biélorussie qui a accueilli des troupes
russes mais pour l'instant les européens
veulent vraiment se concentrer sur
l'objectif principal c'est à dire punir
la russie voit ici le chef de diplomatie
européens
grâce au leadership
précédentes élections
les notes à quest of blocks 10 notes
accueil sonore diplomatique par games et
se mettre au chaud life and death is
balle de flash java gros beaucoup mieux
l'été
le temps l'union européenne
le washington à 12h30 donc tous ont
réagi le plus fortement possible il
faudra voir donc est ce que cette
deuxième vague de sanctions sera
efficace fera mal aux bonnes personnes
autrement dit
ouais c'est la question qui se pose
comment tout cela peut-il avoir un
impact sur la russie puis on sait qu'il
ya des gestes importants quand même
qu'ils ont été posés plus tôt cette
semaine avec la suspension de la
certification de l'est au duc nordstream
dures de la part de l'allemagne pour
l'instant il une unité de la part des
européens patrice y compris la part de
pays qui sont parfois très critiques de
bruxelles la pologne la hongrie mais qui
sont aussi frontalier avec l'ukraine et
le conflit qui se déroule en ce moment
donc pour l'instant il ya une limite et
on verra si elle est maintenue dans le
temps et pour ce qui est de l'otan il ya
eu des rencontres aujourd'hui en aura
aussi demain là évidemment on parle
moins de sanctions économiques mais on
parle de déploiement de troupes pas en
ukraine évidemment parce que l'ukraine
ne fait pas partie de l'otan vous l'avez
abordé abondamment au cours des
dernières minutes mais on veut entre
autres renforcer la présence de l'otan
dans les pays qui sont près de la zone
de conflit à la pologne qui tout juste à
côté de l'ukraine et puis il ya les pays
baltes ou si on sent une grande
nervosité estonie lettonie lituanie qui
sont tout près de la biélorussie et de
la russie donc est question d'envoyer
davantage de troupes y aura une
rencontre demain l'action entre le le
chef le le le secrétaire général de
l'otan a eu des mots très durs lui aussi
à l'endroit de la russie et s'est montré
très inquiet sur ce que représentait ce
qui se passe en ce moment pour l'avenir
de la sécurité européenne et jeux sous
licence en arts compte notre asbl
château de
benauge in europe and steel and over and
over hype
pariez des pays-bas lé de la lettonie le
canada a annoncé plus tôt cette semaine
l'envoi de
466 je croyais 68 militaires canadiens
c'est pour renforcer la présence de
l'otan dans ces trois pays qui eux font
partie de l'otan dans ce serait mon
examen dans les pays baltes et la
crainte de voir les chars d'assaut
russes mais là ce sera une autre
histoire totalement différente très une
attaque frontale contre le temps qui
implique une riposte de l'otan ni repos
l'a très bien merci au jour des pays
membres de l'union européenne et membre
de l'autorité c'est complètement
différent jeudi de vous laisser mais là
non je vous laisse pas tout de suite je
vais une précision sur le premier
milliers de gens tiennent donc vous
dites il va parler au parlement donc
oui c'est ce qui a été annoncé donc
boris johnson a fait une allocution à la
nation plutôt aujourd'hui message
d'ailleurs dans lequel il a qualifié
vladimir poutine de dictateur et il doit
annoncer des mesures supplémentaires
il l'avait fait plus tôt cette semaine
aussi à des sanctions qui avait été
annoncée contre si je ne m'abuse cinq
banques russes et trois oligarques
sanction qui avait été jugée peut-être
pas suffisamment musclée de la part de
l'opposition alors on verra si le
royaume uni va un peu plus loin
évidemment le royaume uni n'est plus
membre de l'union européenne donc prend
ses décisions un peu à part si on veut
par rapport à ce qui va se dérouler à
bruxelles ce soir mais il ya quand même
des appels qui se passe entre autres
entre londres bruxelles et washington
pour tenter d'avoir un effort qui est un
peu concerté qui est un peu comme un
autre merci beaucoup raffin la plus tard
merci de ce compte-rendu ils servent à
je le disais plus tôt
raphaël je sais pas s'ils ont pu lire et
entendre il ya quelque chose de très
fort et de qui résume assez bien quand
on a entendu les sirènes en ukraine
donc anti
bombardements pour prévenir de la
retirer ruche
sirènes qui ont retenti dans une
démocratie européenne on n'avait pas vu
ça depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
encore les auront lieu je vous livrais
réécouter mesdames et messieurs mais il
ya un côté extrêmement fort dans ce qui
se passe symbolique et un potentiel de
déséquilibre de l' équilibre fragile qui
avaient été maintenus quand même depuis
depuis plus de 50 ans 60 ans depuis la
guerre est ce qu on allait est-ce qu'on
a les sirènes sinon raphaël le les yeux
vont être tournés vers la riposte
américaine en termes de rhétorique on
verra ce que le président baden à 12h30
on la laisse rien on va les écouter ça
vous laisse ou l'avait pas entendu
écouté
[Musique]
alors je vous ce je vous rappelle
mesdames et messieurs que nous serons en
émission spéciale une partie de cette
journée marie-eve bédard qui est
toujours à kiev en ukraine tamar altéré
sco qui est à la frontière ukrainienne
et russes l'eau deux collaboratrices
donc à qui on va continuer de parler qui
nous raconte cette histoire depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant choc oui
en ukraine c'est une évidence choc
également en russie tamara disais tout à
l'heure il ya des
embryons de manifestations qui ont
débuté à moscou des russes faut pas
qu'on veut pas faire l'erreur de penser
que les russes sont derrière vladimir
poutine dans sa grille d'un dans ses
intentions guerrières à suivre également
je dis au revoir aux gens de la première
chaîne on va bien sûr sur rdi continuer
à suivre cette crise
alors je le disais assure r d nous
allons continuer nos rendez-vous midi
boris johnson on va essayer de vous
présenter ça en direct il y aura
également un résumé à chaque fois qu'on
a des nouveaux un bilan et tamar
également qui est sur le terrain on va
d'ailleurs tout de suite joindre notre
collègue est ce que marié avet ans est
en mesure de nous parler oui mariah
bonsoir bonsoir à vous et
scellé quoi maintenant six heures à kiev
c'est
on s'est organisé beaucoup de gens
fuient
marie-eve la ville il faut le dire
et beaucoup de gens wiki dès ce matin en
fait dès les premières heures avant même
le lever du soleil qui ont commencé à
prendre la direction ouest du pays on a
vu pendant des heures et des heures
d'immenses bouchons de circulation sur
les artères principales qui mène à
l'extérieur il ya des points de contrôle
qui ont aussi été établi a beaucoup de
contrôle de la circulation et du
personnel on vérifie notre identité
assez régulièrement donc tout ça
ralentit un peu cette évacuation donc ça
c'est le cas pour kiev mais à l'est du
pays aussi on a commencé à orchestrer en
milieu d'après-midi des évacuations ce
qu'on n'avait pas fait pour l'instant
malgré le fait que les combats là bas
était commencé de façon assez soutenue
dès la fin de semaine dernière des
samedis dimanches mais les gens
restaient on a passé beaucoup de temps
au cours des derniers jours dans la
ville de chasse tiers qui a été
aujourd'hui le théâtre de combats très
importants pendant un moment les forces
russes selon le ministère de la défense
ici semblait dominer la situation sur le
terrain il ya quelques heures ils ont
ils ont affirmé avoir repris le contrôle
de cette ville avoir pu chasser les
soldats donc une situation très
dangereuse très incertaine pour la
population qui commence à être acheminée
à l'extérieur du secteur malgré que les
russes aient selon les autorités
ukrainiennes refusé d'accorder un
passage sécurisé pour des convois
d'évacuation est ce qui fait que dans la
plupart des villes où on assiste à des
combats soutenu au delà des frappes
aériennes on dénombre malheureusement
beaucoup de blessés beaucoup de morts de
la population civile le décompte complet
pour la journée patrice je ne saurais
vous le donner mais un peu partout il ya
eu des opérations importantes on parle
toujours d'une quinzaine d'une vingtaine
de blessés au moins parmi eux des
enfants des femmes même chose à peu près
du côté des soldats et c'est
malheureusement aussi le cas de gens qui
sont décédés dans les combats donc les
gens essaient de se mettre à l'abri plus
tôt à l'ouest où la situation demeure
relativement plus calme et on le dit
depuis le début ce sont des cibles
militaires d'abord qui ont été attaquées
par l'artillerie par l'aviation or on ne
sait pas dans quelle mesure vous venez
de le dire les civils il ya des suivez
les dents qu'on en compte quel nombre
ont été blessés ou tués
non c'est ça pour l'instant ce sont les
autorités locales de chacune de ces
villes qui font des rapports assez
régulier mais on ne sait toujours pas
combien de personnes sont d'abord
toujours dans les secteurs qui n'est pas
parti qui reste à la maison donc c'est
une situation qui est très très
inquiétante des cibles civiles oui il ya
eu des bombardements puis ensuite des
combats au sol je pense que dans les
derniers développements ce qui vaut la
peine d'être souligné ce qui est assez
inquiétant d'abord pour la situation
dans la capitale il ya cet aéroport je
vous en parlais tout à l'heure patrice
militaire un peu à l'extérieur de kiev à
quelque 25 kilomètres de la ville de
kiev même aéroport antonov qui serait
maintenant bien en main aux mains des
forces russes qui ont combattu des
soldats ukrainiens qui ont tenté de
résister mais il aurait réussi à
s'emparer de cet aéroport et les combats
le président céline ce qui le disaient
n'y a pas très longtemps il s'est
adressé de nouveau à la population les
combats sont très soutenu encore
maintenant et périlleux at il dit plus
tôt vers le sud du pays là où les
soldats sont arrivés par la crimée donc
dans la région d'odessa mais au delà de
100 autour de la ville de personnes
c'est à peu près à 100 kilomètres
environ à l'intérieur des terres
ukrainiennes il ya encore là des convois
très important et c'est ce qu'on a vu
tout au cours de l'après midi même chose
du côté de karkhiv les combats sont
toujours assez soutenu et c'est la
deuxième ville la plus populeuse de
l'ukraine dont il ya encore énormément
de gens qui sont là le maire un peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui appelé la population à
descendre aux abris dans les métros dans
les sous-sols nous on y était à kharkhiv
il ya un peu plus d'une semaine où les
gens se préparait se préparait pour se
prêter volontaire dans ces milices
citoyennes mais aussi dans les
réservistes qui seraient affiliés à
l'armée se préparer aussi aux premiers
soins en cas d'invasion russe alors nul
doute qu'aujourd'hui tous ces gens qui
ont cherché à se préparer sont mises à
contribution pour tenter d'appuyer les
efforts de l'armée ukrainienne qui ne va
pas céder et l'autre chose c'est qu'il
ya toujours des combats importants et
une tentative
sérieuse de la part des forces russes de
s'emparer d'eux
du site de tchernobyl vous vous souvenez
de la catastrophe nucléaire il ya
toujours des déchets nucléaires là qui
sont entreposés le président zine
indiqué lui-même le disais tout à
l'heure il a prévenu les dirigeants de
la suède de la situation parce que c'est
très inquiétant en fait c'est une
déclaration de guerre contre toute
l'europe a dit vladimir lénine difficile
et russe arrive à s'emparer de ce site
ou via des déchets nucléaires qui
pourraient contaminer non seulement
l'ukraine et le bélarus est ensuite
toute l'europe portés par les vents
pourrait revivre le scénario de 1986 il
a dit que les soldats ukrainienne donné
tout ce qu'ils avaient pour empêcher que
ça ça ne se reproduise je vous en ai
parlé plus tôt mais c'est un c'est un
sujet important vous êtes à kiev donc
dans la mesure où poutine se dire on va
décapité ce régime là il y en aura un
plus sympathique à nous on pourra régler
peut-être la question de l'otan les
ukrainiens on a l'impression corrigez
moi marie-eve je me trompe pas
l'impression que plus cette crise avance
plus les ukrainiens se soude au
contraire et
7 il ya une haine qui se développe
vis-à-vis poutine et les russes
rennes était déjà assez présents depuis
plusieurs jours mais notamment au cours
de la nuit les ukrainiens se sont
entendu dire qu'il n'avait ni véritable
culture ni véritable histoire aucune
légitimité qu'ils étaient une aberration
historique finalement et qu' il avait
choisi démocratiquement un régime nazi
et que les russes venaient ici les
sauver malgré eux ça c'est un message
qui ne passe pas du tout c'est un coup
de poignard que leur envoie le président
russe vladimir poutine les ukrainiens
qui ont fait un choix
en 2014 de se tourner plutôt vers
l'occident qui souhaitent cette adhésion
à l'otan la souhaite peut-être peut-être
pas aussi ardemment pour le citoyen
lambda je vous dirais avant les tensions
des derniers mois mais l'autre de plus
en plus les ukrainiens ont besoin de se
sentir appuyé et de faire partie d'un
système qu'ils ont envie de choisir
volodymyr zelensky dans le discours
qu'il a prononcé le tout dernier parce
qu'il s'adresse régulièrement à la
population disait ce qu'on entend
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le bruit des
bombes le bruit des tirs le bruit des
frappes aériennes
c'est le bruit du rideau de fer qui se
déroule à nouveau et qui va isoler la
russie du reste du monde civilisé on va
l'écouter merci beaucoup marie-eve je
vous reviens on n'a pas l'extrait on l'a
en images b marie-eve rester avec moi
alors je suis désolé parce qu'on a les
images de ce
discours
là un nouveau rideau de fer c'est ce
qu'il explique parce qu'ils parlent en
écrémant séparent maintenant la russie
du monde civilisé on le voit et
marie-eve ce genre de discours là qui
l'envoie là sur les réseaux
donc depuis
depuis le début de cette agression
plusieurs interventions pour soutenir le
moral des ukrainiens soutenir le moral
des troupes aussi il ya une chose on
parle beaucoup des attaques de
l'aviation on parle beaucoup des combats
avec les soldats russes au sol mais
toute cette guerre psychologique qui a
toute sa place aujourd'hui encore des
messages qui sont envoyées aux soldats
qui sont au front par sms à des messages
qui sont envoyées aussi sur les grands
médias russes pour tenter de démoraliser
les ukrainiens pour tenter de 2 de leur
faire baisser les bras quelque sorte de
leur faire craindre que leur armée ne
s'effondre et créé une certaine panique
alors ça il revient aussi assez
régulièrement pour demander aux gens de
rester calmes de faire preuve de
discernement de ne pas être dupe de ces
messages qui leur sont envoyés par
exemple au cours de la journée une
rumeur qui s'est mise à circuler que les
dirigeants ukrainiens avaient commencé à
prendre la fuite qu'ils étaient partis
de kiev ce qui a été démenti par le
ministre de la défense qui disait que
tout ça ça s'inscrit justement dans
cette guerre psychologique qui visent à
saper non seulement le moral des troupes
mais aussi des ukrainiens est prise et
cette solidarité qu'en ce moment ils ont
avec leur président et avec les forces
armées défendent leur pays il n'y a pas
si longtemps marie-eve cet homme était
comédien faisait rire faisait pleurer
avait aucune expérience politique il se
retrouve au carrefour de l'histoire avec
devant lui un défi presque surhumain
quand même incroyable
assez incroyable c'était un comédien qui
rappelez-vous jouait le rôle d'un
président dans une télésérie
humoristique qui a remporté les
élections
c'est un bus aux fans lui même qui est
de l'est du pays
qui est de confession juive aussi
vladimir medinski qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent avec le poids de l'humanité
sur les épaules qui n'était pas
nécessairement apprécié de l'ensemble
des ukrainiens encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup ont des critiques à formuler à
son endroit vous savez il ya eu tous ces
scandales avec
l'élection du président 30 événements
dépression qui avait fait le président
30 sur lui pour se sortir des
informations compromettantes sur le fils
de joe biden à l'époque est ce qui avait
créé un scandale ici ces histoires de
corruption qui ont fait mal à son image
qui ont fait mal un peu à l'appréciation
qu'on les ukrainiens du président yves
hinse qui met aujourd'hui quand on pose
la question aux gens ce qu on nous
répond c'est que en fait il fait tout ce
qu'il peut et on ne peut que l'appuyer
visiblement il est l'homme de la
situation puisque c'est lui qui est
lorsque quelqu'un d'autre aurait fait
mieux que voit le dhimmi réalise qu est
ce qu un autre président aurait pu
attirer l'attention de vladimir poutine
au point de le forcer à s'asseoir à la
table des négociations avec tout ce que
ce qu'a dit le président russe au cours
des dernières heures je pense que les
ukrainiens en arrive à la conclusion que
personne en fait ne pouvait convaincre
vladimir poutine de ne pas passer à
l'action ce qu'on est en train de voir
en ce moment c'est un plan qui est
élaboré visiblement depuis un bon moment
donc les négociations il n'a jamais eu
l'intention de les tenir le dialogue ne
l'intéressent pas marie-eve merci
infiniment on se reparle merci faites
attention merci beaucoup
au revoir
et d'ailleurs zielinski refaite jacob sa
langue maternelle la langue qu'ils
parlent plus facilement si le russe il
quand il parle ukrainiens par la conac
100 russe dans l'est du pays a beaucoup
cette double identité ou en tout cas
culturelle linguistique est très
répandue en ukraine a lancé et là il est
à la tête de pays qui se soude plus que
jamais qu'elle fait sur un indépendant
qui a chassé le pouvoir pro-russe et qui
maintenant est aux prises avec l'attak
du géant à côté absolument peut-être un
point ce serait parce que maria braun
mentionné par rapport au fait qu'il est
juif le président zielinski savez dans
tout ce que le président poutine a pu
dire dans les derniers instants les
derniers jours il a parlé et là je le
cite là de son désir de voir une des
nazification de l'ukraine le contexte du
président ukrainien et lui-même juif et
quand on connaît les implications
historiques de ce qu'on est en train
d'observer il y avait un aspect assez
profondément sur moi je pense qu'ils
méritent d'être mentionnées là à ces
propos la poursuite du président de
lundi qui est et son lien avec les états
unis il ya quelque chose que j'ai vu
pratiquement entièrement oublié façon
collective depuis le début de cette
crise là ce n'est qu'au tout début
littéralement le dante dans la première
semaine de la présidence byden le
président de lenski enfin une entrevue
exclusive à un média américain majeur
accès au spa pas le nommer le
journaliste lui a demandé quelle serait
votre premier message tout premier
message que vous aimeriez envoyé au
nouveau président américain vous savez
ce qui a répondu il a dit qu'il fasse
tout ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
qu'on devienne pays membres de l'otan
donc ces tensions lol effectivement elle
ne date pas d'hier et elle date
certainement pas du moment où monsieur
poutine doit commencer à envoyer ses
troupes à la frontière ukrainienne est
ce que il ya des gens pendant tant d ça
plus souvent au début de la crise - et
là compte tenu de l'agression russe mais
il a des gens qui disent l'otan c'est
une erreur stratégique de de l'essai de
permettre une si grande étendue et
ultime ans à l'ukraine de faire partie
de l'otan que c'était en quelque sorte
une provocation contre le géant russe
dada quelle mesure il n'y a pas des gens
qui disent on aurait peut-être pu être
plus prudent à l'époque compte tenu de
de l'ours qu'on a devant nous beyrouth
et le mot époque et clé je pense pas
triste parce que je dis que c'est pas
commencé hier sa peau contre commencé
non plus avec l'arrivée de joe biden à
la présidence donc à la fois zelensky
hebeisen se retrouve effectivement avec
un géant en colère hors de contrôle
qu'ils ont à gérer mais la réalité c'est
qu'on a vu une dégénération graduelle de
la relation entre la russie et les
etats-unis dans les dernières pages est
ressorti une citation d'un ex
ambassadeur peut-être en fait l'ex
ambassadeur américain le plus connu en
russie mike mcfaul qui mentionnait et ça
c'était en octobre 2000 rappelez-vous le
contexte là on venait de vivre en
septembre et selon lui ce qu'il avait
dit publiquement c'est que le potentiel
pour un renouveau dans une relation dans
la relation entre la russie et les etats
unis n'avaient jamais été aussi
prometteur qui avait un réel potentiel
que ces deux géants l'île de man qui
avaient été les deux grands adversaires
de la guerre froide puissent collaborer
de façon presque sans précédent à
l'époque rappelons-nous le président
bush est en fonction présent poutine est
également fonction c'était sa deuxième
année au kremlin et onu et ça vous et
moi parce qu'on savait parler beaucoup
dans les dernières semaines notamment
dans le téléjournal à quel point une
décision après la au delà de
l'administration bush a provoqué la dîme
et poutine s'est il faut le réaliser wii
u la question de la taille ou la
question de l'expansion à de multiples
reprises notamment au milieu des années
2000 lorsque je suis bausch était en
fonctions que là on a commencé à inclure
des pays qui étaient carrément des
voisins de la russie et d'ex territoire
soviétique mais aussi le soutien
américain aux révolutions qu'on appelait
de couleurs notamment en ukraine
évidemment voisins aussi de la russie et
ex territoire soviétique il ya eu on
l'oubli mais la question de l'évasion de
l'irak qui a profondément choqué la
russie qui étaient diamétralement
opposées la position américaine la
position de l'administration bush qui a
essayé de prévenir et on oublie la
guerre en irak les régionales et racines
les menaces américaines à l'époque où
ces administrations bush de menacer
pardon d'envahir l'iran un allié clé de
la russie dont vous avez eu une cascade
d'événements il faut pas penser que
c'est arrivé dans un vase clos entre la
cades et doit une cascade d'événements
qui ont empoisonné graduellement cette
relation là apprécié et demande de
l'administration obama c'est une
descente aux enfers c'est ça qui nous a
menés à ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose avec ce que l'on
voit
aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous êtes
d'humeur poutine n'a pas poussé un peu
trop loin ce qu'il y aura pas est ce que
cette fois-ci
il sera pas aller trop loin malgré ce
que vous dites que dans son esprit dans
son plaidoyer il ya des raisons
historiques qui font que il peut pas se
permettre d'accepter que l'ukraine
devienne partie de l'otan je vais aller
à ottawa merci rafael vous reste il a
bien sûr laurence martin bon on s'attend
de quoi de monsieur trudeau d'abord
monsieur bail d'une parle en début
d'après-midi -1 trudeau j'imagine va
suivre il ya eu rappelons le la séquence
depuis ce matin une réunion du g7 ou si
oui réunion du g7 à laquelle monsieur
trudeau a participé et oui patrice on
s'attend un point de presse de monsieur
trudeau de madame annan donc la ministre
de la défense attendez vous aussi est-ce
que mélanie joly soit présente sans
doute madame frilet no 6 en après midi
nous dit on n'y a pas encore d'or qui
était confirmé mais il ya deux jours
rappelez-vous le gouvernement trudeau
avait parlé quelques heures après le
gouvernement américain parce que les
mesures qui sont annoncées souvent par
le gouvernement canadien je dirais pas
que c'est un copier coller de ce qui est
annoncé par la maison blanche mais il ya
des grandes ressemblances on n'a qu'à
penser mardi quand justin trudeau a dit
qu'il allait imposer des sanctions
contre des banques russes soutenu par
l'état par le gouvernement de monsieur
poutine par deux banques russes joe
biden avait annoncé exactement la même
chose quand il avait dit on va interdire
aux canadiens de participer à des achats
de la dette souveraine russe c'était la
même chose que monsieur bailon avait
annoncé alors moi ce que j'ai entendu
d'une source gouvernementale
c'est que les nouvelles sanctions là qui
devrait être présenté aujourd'hui
devrait être encore de nature économique
et
mélanie joly donc la milice des affaires
étrangères déjà mardi nous est donné des
indices sur à quoi pourrait ressembler
la ces nouvelles sanctions je pense
qu'on peut voir un extrait de son
discours elle disait des mesures
additionnelles sont prêtes nous sommes
prêts à cibler le secteur financier de
la russie les personnes et les entités
d'importance stratégique
nous sommes prêts à faire une annonce
importante concernant le contrôle des
exportations parce qu'on sait que par
exemple la russie importe entre autres
des hautes technologies de l'occident
est ce que le canada voudra frapper là
dessus c'est ce qu'on verra dans les
prochaines heures donc une annonce qui
est prévue cet après midi peut-être
juste un mot par rapport à l'ambassade
canadienne qui était fermée ce matin à
lviv donc ça c'est dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine où vous savez qu'il ya déjà
deux semaines le canada avait annoncé
qu'il fermait la son ambassade à kiev et
qu'ils la transféraient dans l'ouest du
pays parce qu'on craignait a évidemment
une invasion russe hélas ce qu'on a
appris ce matin c'est que l'ambassadrice
et le personnel tout ce monde là est
rendu en pologne alors ce qu'on me
disait au gouvernement c'est que vont
déjà quand même depuis plusieurs
semaines les canadiens peuvent recevoir
de l'aide consulaire en ligne donc ceux
qui sont sur place vont recevoir des
appuis on l'a vu les numéros à l'écran
là pour recevoir de l'aide depuis le 1er
février le gouvernement canadien demande
à ses ressortissants de quitter le pays
il ya un accord qui a été fait avec
quatre pays limitrophes la roumanie la
hongrie la slovaquie la pologne pour
permettre justement aux canadiens qui
veulent quitter de pouvoir rentrer là
sans entrave dans ces pays donc c'est ce
que les canadiens sur place ne peuvent
faire c'est sûr que ont peu mon la
voyais rien évidemment c'est pas évident
de c'est pas possible de sortir de
l'ukraine mais peut-être par voie
terrestre c'est possible de le faire
avec avec ces quatre pays en ce moment
oui maintenant vers la pologne le le
lien soulignons on parlait à notre
collègue qui était devant l'ambassade de
russie à ottawa une petite manifestation
du credeg symboliquement son talent et
on a vu tout à l'heure à mener le
drapeau ukrainien devant les l'ambassade
russe en disant
on existe en deux mots
le lien il faut ré expliquer aux gens
quand même le lien entre l'ukraine et le
canada est assez fort il ya beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui ont fui l'ukraine à
l'époque ils sont venus dans les
prairies entre autres et à la communauté
ukrainienne est importante au canada oui
c est près d'un million 400 mille
personnes c'est énorme en fait c'est la
troisième plus grande communauté
ukrainienne dans le monde après celles
qui se trouvent évidemment en ukraine et
en russie donc c'est encore plus grand
plus gros que ce qu'on voit même aux
états unis n'ont qu il ya plein de
canadiens qui sont d'origine ukrainienne
on n'a qu'à penser à notre vice première
ministre schirrhein qui elle aussi a
grandi dans les prairies là vous parliez
de l'après notre présence des ukrainiens
dans l'ouest canadien donc c'est son cas
elle donc c'est sûr qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui surveille avec
beaucoup d'attention ce qui se passe en
ce moment en ukraine je sais qu'il ya
déjà ce soir à ottawa une manifestation
qui est prévu devant l'ambassade russe
je pense autour de 17h donc en soutient
évidemment à l'ukraine et c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a vu par exemple
ya quelques minutes à queen's park donc
à l'assemblée législative de l'ontario
tous les partis politiques exprimé leur
soutien à l'ukraine et d'oxford
justement a parlé de l'importance des
ukrainiens dans l'héritage canadien dans
l'histoire canadienne je pense qu'on
peut entendre un extrait de son discours
de grenoble de foudre
mais voilà des liens très forts oui oui
exactement et la chef de l'opposition
officielle à queen's park donc andré
harvard du npd a dit on est prêt à
accueillir des réfugiés sas a fait écho
aussi à ce que nadine giro au québec a
dit un peu plus tôt ce matin là aussi on
écoute
on n'a pas de madame giroux elle a dit
on ou non au brand oui on ouvre nos bras
et exactement parce qu'on peut
s'attendre évidemment à skis et beaucoup
de réfugiés ou craignant qu'ils quittent
vers l'europe mais ensuite peut-être
qu'ils voudront justement venir au
canada étant donné qu'il ya toute cette
communauté ukrainienne et qui a déjà
plein de familles ici qui sont installés
donc à suivre plus tard aujourd'hui
c'est intéressant de voir toute l'unité
qui avait à queen's park justement
est-ce que à ottawa on verra le même
genre d'unité de la propagande du parti
conservateur du blog du npd se ranger
derrière monsieur trudeau derrière sa
réponse parce qu'on a vu quand même peut
penser que oui comme on peut on peut
penser que oui parce que ça a été comme
vous le savez très très tendue à vouloir
politiquement dans les dernières
semaines donc ça serait un changement de
ton importante de la part des partis
politiques des choses qui rassemble
évidemment un fondamental très bien
merci beaucoup et on vend washington
parce qu'elle est ce qu'on a des détails
d'abord sur le g7 est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont sortis et à l'isi voilà
donc les membres du g7 se parler ce
matin ça commençait à un peu après 9h ce
matin hélas dans l'entente qui a été
rédigé de la main de tous les membres du
g7 on prend une position très ferme à
l'égard de la russie ont dit que la
russie actuellement menace l'ordre
mondial avec sa décision d'aller de
l'avant dans son attaque en ukraine
aussi que la russie s'inscrit du mauvais
côté de l'histoire tout simplement avec
cette décision là on demande aussi à la
russie de faire de déployer tous les
efforts pour assurer que des
observateurs déployés par l'osce et des
oeufs puisse arriver en ukraine pour
pouvoir regarder ce qui se passe sur le
terrain on a profité aussi de l'occasion
pour dire que cette décision d'un russie
violet toute la charte et les principes
fondateurs de l'onu
en allant de l'avant aussi le g7 a
écorché le pays voisins de l'ukraine le
bélarus en disant qu'il fallait
condamner le fait que le pays justement
accueillez les troupes russes les pays
du g7 ont aussi une petite pensée pour
la crise énergétique le qui pourrait
survenir en lien avec tout ce qui se
passe les pays du g7 disait déjà être
prêt et coordonner des actions entre eux
pour s'assurer que les ressources
énergétiques que les pénuries
énergétiques pourraient être colmatée il
pourrait répondre aux besoins le des
citoyens des pays du g7 quelle est la
lecture qu'on fait le pentagone est-ce
qu'on décrit le genre d'opération
militaire que l'on observe même un petit
peu moins d'une heure là il ya eu
justement un briefing technique qui a
été offert aux journalistes mais pour
l'instant ce que le pentagone
remarque c'est que toutes les ressources
militaires que la russie possède c'est
assez logique donc pas encore été
déployés donc pour l'instant on ne peut
pas chiffrer le nombre de troupes russes
qui ont traversé du côté ukrainien mais
on estime que c'est encore une petite
proportion des troupes qui étaient mises
à la disposition de la russie qu'ils
l'ont fait pour l'instant
et on a mis un peu un mot sur sûr qu à
quoi sert le fonds sert actuellement
elle servirait selon le pentagone a
décapité le pouvoir à kiev pour
éventuellement installer son propre
pouvoir russe qui gouvernerait l'ukraine
par contre on remarque que le que les
forces d'ukrainiens sont là se défendre
et résiste pour l'instant mais comme je
vous le disais c'est loin d'être toutes
les ressources russes qui ont été
déployés pour le moment
très bien merci beaucoup décapité le
pouvoir
ukrainien donc voilà la lecture du
pentagone et
on le disait 12h30 joe biden qui doit
s'adresser aux américains au monde c'est
pas exagéré de le dire dans ce que si au
monde à 12h30 il ya le premier ministre
britannique mais j'ai hâte d'entendre le
ton du premier ministre britannique a
mis 10 j'espère qu'on sera en mesure de
le pressing on récupère une partie au
parlement au parlement britannique
raphaël
décapité le pouvoir ukrainien ça c'est
une chose puis sont capables le faire
assez vite
c'est une autre chose de faire durer sa
dans le temps parce qu'il faut que ya
déjà une révolution pour chasser un
pouvoir pro russe en ukraine comment
fait-on une fois qu'on a fait ça j'ai
j'imagine que on n'est pas rendu là du
côté de moscou deux choses premièrement
pour ce qui est des qualités justement
le gouvernement actuel de l'ukraine ça
vient de sortir dans les dix dernières
minutes marco rubio qui est un des
centres américains républicains
probablement les plus influents les plus
importants sur les questions de
politique étrangère et je dirais qu'il
ya relativement leur visé dans le mille
depuis les derniers jours pour ce qui
est de d'anticiper ce qui allait se
produire sur le terrain vient d'envoyer
un message comme quoi il s'attendait à
ce que dans les prochaines heures
parfois de semaine ou même deux jours le
dans les prochaines heures les troupes
russes cherchent à encercler kiev la
capitale ce qui mènerait évidemment à
une chute lors on comprend leur a s'est
précipitée du gouvernement ukrainien
autrement dit ce pas une prédiction mais
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
envisagée de façon je crois extrêmement
sérieuse ça vient des plus hautes
instances du pouvoir du sénat américain
présentement social chose poursuit la
deuxième chose que vous avez mentionné
présumant qu'on compare bien faire ça du
côté russe qu'ont fait tomber le
gouvernement
la pression devient dont on entend la
phrase qui peut être plus difficile en
fait pour le 10 mai prochain dépôt la
russie et j'ai le goût là dessus pas
triste de vous citer en fait un homme
dont on s'est parlé ya pas très
longtemps parce qu'il est décédé l'ex
secrétaire d'état américain colin powell
qui on se parlait aussi de ça il ya
quelques instants lorsqu'est venu le
temps pour les états unis d'envahir
l'irak je suis pas au niveau de mettre
la secrétaire d'état de george bush et
avait essayé de le convaincre de ne pas
envahir l'irak et la réplique du célèbre
c'était la suivante vous allez me
pardonner l'utilisation pardon
bref de l'anglais l'avait dit you bring
your own est autrement dit à partir du
moment où vous prenez le contrôle d'un
pays étranger vous en devenir
responsable et pour ça pour monsieur
poutine je reviens l'océan un hôtel
qu'on aborde et tantôt il ya
potentiellement un risque considérable
donc on n'est pas là mais c'est très
possible qu'on se dirige vers la et sa
relativement rapidement oui s'ils
avaient en ukraine par exemple une forte
volonté en fait une volonté qu'elle soit
forte ou pas une volonté de vivre avec
un pouvoir pro-russe à l'allumette gare
un espace pour lui mais avec ce qui est
arrivé depuis un mois plus beaucoup
d'ukrainiens
qui sont chauds à l'idée de 200 lignes
s'aligner avec la politique d avec le
géant poutine mais c'est ça c'est que
c'est un pays je vais envoyer et
conquérir en guillemets et donner
responsable d'un pays étranger voire
presque toujours être une tâche
extrêmement important demain pour une
puissance comme la russie mais la
réalité c'est que là il pas simplement
question d'un pays étranger est question
d'un pays qui ultra déchiré et divisé de
l'ain terme depuis des années pas
seulement depuis le début de la crise
depuis un mois depuis des années et oui
c'est une chose de reprendre un contrôle
implicite ou explicite de l'est du pays
la fameuse région du dombass dont on
parle tellement cerner toute une autre
de prendre le contrôle et de devenir
responsable de l'ouest du pays qui pour
des raisons ne serait-ce que
géographique évidente est beaucoup plus
proche culturellement économiquement
politiquement de l'europe de l'union
européenne et de l'accident de façon
plus large donc devenir responsable de
site de cette partie là et ce sont des
dizaines de millions de résidents c'est
pas un voisin comme les autres pour la
russie il sait aussi qu'il faut réaliser
donc effectivement il ya un risque qui
est important je sais acheter quelque
chose si on entend patrice en tête quant
aux nominés oui oui ok parce qu'on en
parle beaucoup et à juste titre la des
efforts qui sont déjà menées qui vont
consommer être menée par les pays
occidentaux menée notamment par les
etats-unis pour isoler la russie bien
vous réalisez que la russie même si ces
efforts-là song mais fructueux n'est pas
isolé on est dans un monde qui de plus
en plus multipolaire on n'est plus dans
le monde par exemple la bosnie et du
kosovo lorsqu'il avait eu une peut-être
la dernière vraiment guerre importante
en sol européen il ya peu près 20 ans on
a oui la russie on a aussi la chine
rappelez-vous ce qui s'est passé au tout
début des jeux olympiques je parle pas
des jeux olympiques il ya 4 ou 8 ans je
parle des jeux olympiques qui ont
commencé ce mois-ci xinping et vladimir
poutine ont publiquement annoncé non
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas une alliance
officiel ils ont quand même annoncé un
partenariat stratégique formelle et ça
mérite d'ajouter ça aussi dans lequel il
n'y aurait aucune limite aucune limite
c'est le terme exact qu'ils ont utilisés
pour parler de leur partenariat
autrement dit ce ne sont pas plusieurs
joueurs ce sont plusieurs gros joueurs
qui peuvent être entraînés directement
ou indirectement dans ce conflit là je
pense qu'il ya sa garde et en taille de
façon importante présente l'asile où l
on disait tout à l'heure si poutine peut
le faire le président chi pourrait
penser qui pourra le faire aussi
ailleurs il a donc mais là restons
restons sur moi si disons on a donc
à vladimir poutine on parle actuellement
donc est-ce qu'on a est ce qu'on est du
son une traduction je ne peux pas nier
ce beau temps quelque chose de triste
kim eun hye min de jeu politique tous
ces bruits émis et eric seboun tout
alors nouveautés suisse il explique que
les efforts ont été vains il plaide
qu'il a fait des efforts qui aurait
voulu agir différemment mais qui a été
je le sais forcé de prendre ces mesures
guerrière et
que la russie dit-il prévient-il entend
rester une partie importante de
l'économie internationale donc c'est un
une menace envers l'occident 10 ans ne
pensait pas que vous allez m'exclure de
votre grand marché des échanges j'y suis
j'y reste
alors voilà quasiment poutine trier les
labos 19 heures un peu plus ma 20h
s'adresse aux russes et à la planète
j'en fais les bios pendant qu'il parle
au kremlin
il a depuis la nuit dernière lancé une
attaque on le rappelle tout azimuts sur
l'ukraine vont lui viennent plaider qui
avait pas le choix c'est évidemment pas
la vie d'à peu près tous les autres
joueurs la communauté internationale
alors on va re résumé ce qui a été fait
depuis plusieurs heures sur le terrain
militaire
oui tout à fait don pour vivre sur les
derniers développements cette invasion
russe qui vise d'abord et avant tout des
cibles militaires géo stratégiques afin
de justement annulé la possibilité de
l'ukraine de riposter de se défendre
dernière image ça c'est la base de
milito paul c'est sur la mer d'azov une
mère que partage l'ukraine et la russie
des images authentifié par cnn vous
voyez la force des frappe donc pour
mettre hors jeu finalement les troupes
les troupes l'ukrainien mais aussi tous
les systèmes de défense d'ukrainiens je
vous fais la géographie rapidement de ce
qui s'est passé depuis hier soir tout
d'abord à partir du nord les troupes
sont descendus du bélarus pour envahir
l'ukraine palais trop bélarus les
troupes russes qui étaient postés du
côté du bélarus alors on va commencer du
côté de tchernobyl où il ya présentement
des combats d'ailleurs le président
zielinski a écrit sur twitter que les
forces russes essaient de saisir donc
tchernobyl nos soldats sacrifient leur
vie pour éviter que la tragédie de 1986
ne se répète encore et donc c'est une
déclaration de guerre contre l'ensemble
de l'europe il essaie justement de
sensibiliser l'europe aux dangers de ce
qui se passe sur son territoire
présentement si on descend un peu plus
au sud en automne l importante base
militaire où il ya de violents combats
présentement bbc a authentifié cette
image d'un hélicoptère russe qui
auraient été abattues par les forces du
craignent un sur le terrain qui assure
une défense tant bien que mal de ce côté
maintenant m en mer noire il ya un
navire sûr que c'est pas un navire de
guerre un navire turc a été atteint par
des bombardements russe on présume pas
de blessés toutefois le navire s'est
ensuite déplacé vers la roumanie mais le
risque de tels incidents c'est que
d'autres pays se sentent attaqués et
qu'il y ait l'effet domino qui a créé
deux grandes guerres par le passé
maintenant les russes eux visent les
installations militaires on le voit si
le quartier général du renseignement
ukrainien qui a été atteint en matinée
ici c'est un aéroport celui celui de
chez goueff dont l'aéroport militaire
les installations donc ukrainienne
touché 74 installations militaires selon
les russes ont été atteintes aux
aérodromes ont aussi été mis hors
service selon les russes n'est pas
nécessairement une opinion qui est
partagé du côté ukrainien regardez la
force des frappe lorsqu'elles atteignent
leur cible les explosions comme celle là
il y en a eu plusieurs depuis hier au
moins deux quarantaine de soldats
chrétiens sont morts mais c'était des
bilans très tôt en matinée c'est
probablement plus élevé à l'heure où on
se parle je vous dis en toute
transparence parce que les bilans arrive
très lentement depuis hier donc d'autres
explosions qui ont eu lieu du côté des
russes selon l'ukraine ils ont abattu 50
soldats russes six avions russes ainsi
qu'un hélicoptère russe probablement
celui qu'on voyait sur les photos un peu
plus tôt
la guerre fait aussi des blessés chez
les civils pas seulement chez les
militaires comme tentent de le prétendre
la russie cette femme a été grièvement
blessé en raison des bombardements à
kiev les gens tentent tant bien que mal
de se réfugier de protéger les leurres
leurs enfants en allant par les stations
de métro sous le sol qui font office de
bunker à l'heure actuelle parce que les
gens n'ont nulle part où aller dans la
capitale kiev il ya eu des bombardements
ou cours des dernières heures est trop
de frais non loin de la capitale selon
des rapports compte avancer d'autres
grands médias internationaux
les gens font la file dans les rues
présentement pour tenter de mettre la
main sur des billets de banque bien que
ce soit limitée en ce moment donc la
quantité d'argent qu'on peut retirer les
voitures font la file pour mettre de
l'essence alors voilà c'est les biens de
première nécessité que les gens tentent
de ceux de se procurer dans les minutes
les heures avant que ça ne s'empire en
pleine nuit les gens tentés de quitter
laquelle la capitale pour se mettre à
l'abri certains tentent de fuir le pays
d'ailleurs sista l'aéroport défilent
importante on peut voir sur les rappeler
les radars sur internet y avait plus de
vols en ukraine alors les gens ont
attendu tant bien que mal d'autres se
sont rendus directement aux frontières
comme la frontière polonaise qu'on peut
voir juste ici la pologne avait
d'ailleurs demandé à ses ressortissants
donc de quitter l'ukraine faute d'être
en mesure de les défendre si jamais il
devait y avoir des débordements
importants dans les prochaines heures et
les prochains jours merci beaucoup de ce
tour d'horizon de cette opération
militaire
je le disais mesdames et messieurs il ya
quelques minutes la gym est possible que
vous voyez les jours en direct selon ou
intervention en deux mots il plaide
qu'il a essayé d'autres options avant
d'entrain des craintes sans succès il
dira de l'eau qui n'avait pas le choix
qu'il a été forcé de prendre des actions
un militaire il assure que la russie
fait et fera encore partie de l'économie
mondiale qu'il ne peut pas prévoir quels
sont les risques géopolitiques mondiaux
nos partenaires dit il devrait
comprendre il ne devrait pas nous
pousser à l'extérieur du système le sous
texte comprenez que je ne pouvais pas
tolérer que l'ukraine puisse un jour
devenir membre de l'otan ne devienne une
menace alors laissez-moi faire en
ukraine sinon ça sera le prix à payer
pour vous communauté internationale ou
si il ya un gros est professeur d'études
de l'international collège royal
militaire de saint jean cette co auteur
du livre la russie et son ex empire qui
redevient en partie son empire
reconfigurer sur géopolitique alors on
est en plein dedans mais je bros
votre résumé comment vous résumer
ce qui se passe depuis la nuit derrière
mon dieu c'est l'aboutissement d'un
effort de renégociation du rapport de
force entre la russie et l'otan qui
durent patrice depuis plus de 20 ans
l'histoire c'est difficile de se
détacher des choses atroces qui sont en
train de se dérouler sur sous nos yeux
et j'en parle avec avec avec l'émotion
et grands troubles j'ai passé une
franchement une mauvaise nuit
mais tout a commencé en 99 quand l'otan
pris la décision d'autres partis sont
marrants deuil et de bombarder une
latéralement sans l'aval du conseil de
sécurité un état qui s'appelait encore à
l'époque la yougoslavie
c'est le moment un cliché tout l'état
major russe on s'est aperçu que l'otan
ni des plus strictement une alliance
défensive mais c'était une alliance
destinée à jouer un jour ou deux
gendarmes l échelle internationale et à
l'époque la réussite est bien trop
faible pour tenter de résister à son nom
sera pile qui avait le ministre des
affaires étrangères primakov qui avait
fait 1-1 hughton au dessus de
l'atlantique angers en guise de
protestation eltsine parlait de sa
puissance nucléaire et on s'en moque et
dans les chancelleries occidentales
parce que la russie venait de connaître
une période de croissance de son pib de
50% dans la décennie des années 1990 et
7,7 rangs carlos et sentiments les cette
volonté de revanche isme genre parlé
dans un article
mon directeur de taille jacques lévesque
on parlait de revanchisme russe déjà
dans les milieux déjà cinq six ans et il
ya des appels lieux décrits qui sont
lancés on pense au fameux discours de
poutine en 2007 où l'on venait de
reconnaître un état qui n'en étaient pas
besoin c'est-à-dire le kosovo dont
convenait en droit international de
commettre un peu le même crime que les
russes ont commis cette semaine en
reconnaissant ses territoires
sécessionnistes là et poutine disait
haut et fort l'époque du monde
unipolaire américain c'est un péril pour
le système international
il va devoir y avoir un rééquilibrage
des forces qui s'opèrent à l'échelle
internationale et ils refluent 20 ans
avant qu'on en arrive à ce geste que je
qualifie presque désespérée puisque bout
de ses ennemis en décembre sur la table
des propositions qui nous ont semblé
tellement audacieux il est presque
ridicule l'otan a répondu avec poutine
non sans quelques arrogance en disant si
on souhaite avoir des garanties de
sécurité en europe il faudrait d'abord
que vous retiriez les troupes qui sont
stationnés illégalement en géorgie dans
les républiques autoproclamées de 7,6 du
sud et d'abkhazie il faudrait le faire
aussi en moldavie où il ya des anciennes
troupes soviétiques qui sont stationnés
dans la région sécessionniste de
transnistrie faudra le faire en ukraine
bref on accuse une fin de non recevoir
aux demandes russe on s'est prêté au jeu
au ballet diplomatique et je pense que
poutine a tiré la conclusion non les
français les allemands n'arriverait pas
en faire pression sur le pouvoir à kiev
pour faire respecter les accords de
cessez-le-feu de 2015 conclut à minsk et
l'on vient d'entrer dans une autre une
autre dimension dont les ramifications
internationales on parle à juste titre
la chine qui regarde ça de très près
donc je suis juif julien clay est
bouleversée je suis troublé et où
surtout un peu fâché de danger toujours
fait la prédiction que poutine se
comporter quand même d'une façon
pragmatique et rationnel il calcule et